. Danke schön, hallo Köln! Hey Köln, was geht? Danke schön, bitte ist zu groß. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast-Ufren-Live-Show in Köln. Hey, was geht? Stefan, danke schön, danke, sehr nett. Wir haben nicht gedacht, dass ihr so positiv auf uns reagiert. Schön, dass ihr das einrichten könntet, fantastisch. Danke, setzt euch, setzt euch, kommt runter vom Stuhl jetzt, setzt euch. Unsere erste Idee war vielleicht hier aufzutreten. Von hier, das Problem, wir müssten einfach anderthalb Stunden vorher warten, bis ihr alle sitzen. Das wäre der Effekt gewesen, aber wäre auch nicht so gut gewesen. Unser Problem heute ist, wir haben ein bisschen zu viel Platz. Wir wollten ursprünglich wiederball spielen, aber es ist schwierig. Wie hast du jetzt? So ein bisschen die 3D-Erfahrung, ihr seht mit dem rechten Auge immer Stefan und mit dem linken immer mich. Und am Ende ist es dann total dreidimensional. Es ist zu viel Platz, muss man sagen. Sag mal, Leute, was glaubt ihr eigentlich, wer ihr seid? Ja, ganz kurz mal eben. Wir hätten pünktlich angefangen, okay? Wir hätten um 20 Uhr angefangen. Und dann kam plötzlich, kam jemand aufgeregt, hat gesagt, nee, nee, nee, ruhig euch wieder, ihr könnt euch wieder hinsetzen, es kommen Leute zu spät. Was hattet ihr heute Abend vor, dass ihr zu spät kommt? Ihr kommt zu spät. Ihr seid Teil der Podcast-Suche-Community, okay? Wir kommen nicht zu spät. Wir kommen gar nicht oder pünktlich. Wir sind die, die zu früh da sind. Zu früh dann die ganzen Erdnüsse essen und dann gehen, bevor die anderen Gäste kommen. Das ist die Podcast-Suche-Community. Richtig, wir sind die, die zu früh sind, mit dem Car2Go, im Auto sitzen bleiben wollen, dann die Miete beenden, aber noch im Auto sitzen, weil sie noch nicht reingehen wollen. Ja, und vier Leute haben jetzt ihr Smartphone rausgeholt. Fakt, meine Cart-to-go-Miete läuft gerade noch. Aber das ist mir wirklich passiert. Ich bin zu einem Business-Treffen, ich bin zu früh gekommen und dann war es mir unangenehm, davor zu warten. Und ich bin mit dem Cart-to-go gekommen gekommen. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja was mache ich denn jetzt, weil ich wollte auch nicht an dem Auto lehnend halt warten, bis die anderen Leute kommen, dann bin ich im Auto sitzen geblieben. Das Problem ist, die Miete läuft ja weiter und dafür war ich zu geizig. Dafür war ja das Business-Treffen da, da bin ich nicht mehr zu geizig sein muss. Und jemand wie du kann sich auch nicht hinter dem Smart verstecken, das ist das Problem. Als normal das ist richtig. Ich habe versucht mich drüber zu legen, aber dabei habe ich das das Smart angehoben leider. Das stimmt, mittlerweile bist du nicht nur gross, sondern auch fett und damit in allen Dimensionen. Ja, ja, okay, alles da, gut, gut, gut. Du, ich muss die drei Wochen nutzen, in denen du fetter bist als ich, okay? Das ist so ein Wenn-Diagramm, das nur ganz, ganz kleines Fitzelstück hat, das muss ich ausnutzen. Das stimmt, und dann habe ich tatsächlich da drin gewartet und habe dann die Miete beendet. Und dann kommt so ein Geräusch, was man erkennt, wenn man das Auto von außen abschließt, nur man ist halt innen. War das Auto abgeschlossen? Und ich dachte mir, das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass das geht. Aber es geht. Und dann habe ich die Miete beendet und der Wagen war wieder freigegeben für die Öffentlichkeit. Heißt, es hätte jemand an dieser Straße vorbeigehen können, findet ein Car2Go und sagt, okay, das nehme ich jetzt, ist ja frei, weil es in der App steht, dass es frei ist, macht das Wagen auf und dann sitze ich da drin und sage, wir fahren jetzt da wohin, wo du willst. Wir sind jetzt zusammen, das ist jetzt einfach das Car2Go-Regel. Ich wollte auch nicht, dass das passiert. Mein Problem ist, ich bin oft zu pünktlich im Sinne von, wenn es heißt, rufe mich um um drei an, rufe ich um fünfzehn Uhr null null null null Sekunden an. Weil ich wirklich schon die ganzen acht Minuten davor mit Schweißtrief in den Händen vor meinem Handy sitze und den Fak Fak Fak die Sekunden hört auf zu ticken und dann um exakt drei Uhr tätigen Anruf. Aber ich glaube, dann hast du es geschafft, wenn du nicht mehr darauf achtest, sondern wenn du einfach irgendwann anrufst, wann es gerade passt. Diese drei Nachleute, was sind das denn für Leute? Die haben es dann geschafft. Wir hingegen, bei uns ist das der Plan, bei uns ist das der Tag. Der Tag, an dem drei Uhr der Anruf ist. So, ich nehme jetzt vier Stunden Zeit, um ein dreiminütiges Telefonat zu führen. Einfach so zwei Stunden lang mentale Vorbereitung, drei Minuten, leider nicht rangegangen und dann zwei Stunden. Es ist seltsam, aber ich weiß nicht, wenn ich Reisetage habe, wo man mit dem ICE meinetwegen nur eine Stunde nach Dortmund fährt, dann ist das mein Tag. Ich lege mir nichts anderes mehr auf diesen Tag, das ist mein Reisetag. Das ist der Tag, wo ich mir vorher ein YouTube-Video runterlade, das dann schaue und dann fahre. Und dann frage ich mich immer irgendwie, das ist mir so Selbstbetrug, danach frage ich mich, was mache ich mit dem Rest des Tages. Aber man ist halt eine eine stunde hingefahren das stimmt jetzt gerade zu weihnachten sind die züge ja sehr voll das funktioniert sehr super das funktioniert da ist die weihnachtsdikoration wir haben gesagt immer wenn wir weihnachten sagen wird's weihnachtlich kommen leute zwei leute zwei streber aus der ersten verdammt nochmal einmal was vor es ist manchmal nicht so leicht macht wieder aus jetzt macht einmal was vor. Ey, es ist manchmal nicht so leicht, macht's wieder aus, jetzt macht's aus, der Moment ist vorbei. Es ist echt nicht so leicht, wir versuchen uns hier richtig was Geiles zu überlegen für euch. Hier sowas kommt, das interessiert den Scheiss, da nicht einmal Bananentee und hier rastet aus. Habe ich schon bei Radio Nucular gesehen, sowas kommt da hin. Wir haben so einen extra Weihnachtsbaum auf die Bühne gestellt. Davor. Weil wir da... Komm, wir machen es. Wir haben gesagt, klar, heute ist wahrscheinlich die letzte Folge vor Weihnachten, deswegen ist man es wahnsinnig geblendet auch davon. Wir haben ihn vor allem extra dargestellt, damit die Person, die ganz vorne links sitzen muss, jetzt nach rechts guckt. Richtig scheisse, oder? Früh gekommen, erste Reihe und dann das. Aber ganz Ganz kurz, jetzt will ich mal von dir wissen.
Floget,, Arme hoch.
Danke, danke.
Ganz kurz.
Bei Seiten stechen Arme hoch.
Sorry.
Woher kommst du?
Überbrück kurz.
Ich wiege jetzt nicht mehr 100 Kilo.
Ich habe schon vier Kilo abgenommen.
Weil ich sag, ich, ja, ja. Das stimmt wirklich. Es geht doch hier weiter. Nee, das war ganz kurz. Ich saß mal in dem Kilo ganz vorne links und dann guckt man ja nach rechts und denkt sich, wenn ich jetzt zwei Stunden lang nach rechts gucke, dann ist ja mein gesamter Organismus aus dem Gleichgewicht gebracht. Also wenn man zwei Stunden nur nach rechts schaut, dann haben wir den Rest des Lebens über, also dann ist es ja mehr. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ihr müsst die gleiche Zeit auch nach links gucken und habe dann gedacht, irgendwann im Film so, jetzt ist eine Szene, die ist nicht so wichtig, da kann ich, also wenn hier die Leinwand ist, kann ich auch immer den machen. Planst du Ähnliches? Nein, okay, gut. Okay, wir können dir ein Zeichen geben, falls eine Stelle kommen, wo wir sagen können, die ist nicht so wichtig, da kannst du auch einfach nach links gucken die ganze Zeit. Lustigerweise, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich noch daran erinnerst, dass wir bei Louis CK waren und ihn gesehen haben. Bei Louis CK in Amsterdam, sorry, ich wollte die... Diese lustigen Stuhlgags wollten wir doch für später aufhören, wenn es gar nicht mehr geht. Und tatsächlich war dann da die Bühne und man hat die ganze Zeit so gesessen, weil es eine Arena war. Ich sass relativ mittig neben dir und dann musste man halt die ganze Zeit so gucken auf die Bühne und irgendwann konnte ich nicht mehr. Und neben mir sass halt eine ältere Frau und irgendwann dachte ich mir, ja fuck it, gucke in die andere Richtung und sie war völlig verwirrt, haben sie was verloren, haben sie den Handy-Fall. Die Bühne oder was? Ja, aber ich hab dann einfach kurz irgendwie so zwei Minuten lang sie angeguckt, weil es nicht mehr ging, einfach vom Nacken. Ist auch am Flugzeug immer so, du schaust die ganze Zeit aus dem Fenster und irgendwann kommt jemand wo du sagst, jetzt wurde der Übel, hallo, schön, dass du da bist. Dann kommt meistens die Frau mit den Snacks, aber man hat dann schon einen verringten Nacken und konnte nicht wirklich gucken. Ey, wir haben Louis Sikai gesehen und der wurde wurde ja übertragen, nochmal komplett auf Bildschirmen. Das ist schon krass. Also ruft uns da kurz bitte an, wenn das der Level ist, den wir erreicht haben, dass wir übertragen müssen auf einem Bildschirm, dann sollen wir aufhören. Schreibt da kurz eine Mail. Man guckt vor allem die ganze Zeit auf dem Bildschirm und man denkt sich, ich habe bezahlt dafür, dass ich ihn live sehe. Ich will nicht auf dem Bildschirm gucken, aber man macht es irgendwie, weil man ihn da besser sieht. Also die Lehre daraus, einfach Netflix gucken. Schön ein Netflix Special gucken. Im Grunde schon. Kein Sponsoring. Ich habe mich heute modisch mal ein bisschen sicherer angezogen, könnt ihr vielleicht sehen. Du siehst wie ein alter Mann aus. Danke. Automatisch. Ja, es hat sowas, aber ich freue mich ja auf die Rente, weil es hat so, mir ist alles scheiss egal. Hast du nicht mal gesagt, der beste Zustand für dich wäre, verwitwet zu sein? Ja, im Ernst, denkt drüber nach, denkt drüber nach. Verwitwet heißt, niemand, weil das Dumme am Single-Sein ist ja immer, dass man so bedenkt, man hätte jetzt, man müsste jetzt irgendwie jemand finden. Die Gesellschaft zwingt dir in eine Beziehung auf. Die Gesellschaft sieht nicht vor, dass es glückliche Single gibt. Jeder, der sagt, ich bin Single, sagt, hier, ich kenne meine Tante Frieda, da ist der Mann gerade verwest gerade, nimm die doch. Und deswegen, das Beste ist, wenn du Witwer bist, dann sagen alle, ah ja, okay, der muss dann auch drüber kommen und niemand hat den Druck und du hast deine fucking Ruhe. Der muss seit 80 Jahren drüber hinweg kommen. Ja, und du hast seine fucking Ruhe einfach so, das ist eigentlich perfekt. Ein alter Witwer, das finde ich richtig schön, weil es ist einfach alles scheissegal, was soll passieren, ich soll sterben? Es ist einfach völlig egal. Der Punkt, wo du, wenn du rückwärts aus deiner Einfahrt rausfährst, nicht mehr nach hinten guckst. Das ist der Moment, wo du sagst, fuck it, fuck it, das ist mir scheissegal. Das ist wirklich, dann hast du das wirklich geschafft, aber ich frage mich, wann ist der Tag erreicht? Wann sagt man sich, jetzt fange ich nicht mehr nach hinten, wann fährt man einfach zurück? Einfach, dass man sagt, oh Scheisse. Es kracht halt. Wird das Maximalalter des Menschen schneller höher als wir altern? Also werden wir jetzt gleich gar nicht mehr. Das ist eine Frage der Zeit, bis wir einen Soziologen brauchen oder was auch immer das studium dafür ist unser podcast soziologe herzlich willkommen er kam auch zu spät typisch soziologen weil sie wissen wie soziale gruppen funktionieren und zu spät ist immer ein bisschen cooler und die lassen sich nicht darauf ein haa gruppenzwang sagt dass ich komme mir doch egal nicht bei erschien. Ich glaube, es kann sein, dass es gibt eine Generation, die nicht mehr alt wird, weil das Maximale
Alter so schnell wächst, schneller wächst, als man selber.
Ganz kurz nochmal, es gibt eine Generation, die nicht mehr altert, weil ...
Momentan kannst du ja sagen, keine Ahnung, das maximale Lebensalter erhöht sich alle vier Jahre um ein Jahr.
Kann man sagen. Aber was ist, wenn man jetzt sagt, wenn es jetzt so krass da wird, hört mal auf, hört mal auf. Wer widerspricht, fliegt raus, aber sofort. Ich glaube, man hat es das Gefühl, jetzt zu lachen, weil man nicht weiß, was für andere Reaktionen von einem verlangt wird. Zustimmen, dafür weiß man zu wenig, nein sagen. Das ist wie in so einem Rollenspiel, wenn alle drei Antworten scheiße sind und man sich denkt, wo ist ,,ssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss ist das. Ja, genau. Das sieht man selten am Frankfurter Flughafen, sieht man selten Mallorca, Ibiza, Antarktis. Ja. Wo ist das Grönland wahrscheinlich und dann erstmal Trampen. Und der hat versucht, da durchzulaufen und hat es nicht geschafft, ist gestorben, erfroren, tot. Aber leider. Ist das nicht lustig, dass du so eine Re, wo das Ergebnis niemanden verwundert, wenn du stirbst, niemand sagt dann, was ist passiert, er ist gestorben, die Verwandten sagen doch dann, also ich muss sagen, damit gerechnet. Leute haben schon den Nachruf geschrieben, die Todesanzeige der Schnellzeitung. Was ist eigentlich mit Herbert geworden, der vor zehn Jahren versucht hat, alleine die Antarktis zu durchqueren? Der ist tot. Achso, das hat mich jetzt nicht überrascht. Und der hat dann, das ist wirklich dramatisch, und der ist erfroren und hat mit seinen Freunden gesagt so, okay, wir erfrieren in 24 Stunden. Noch schnell einen Schneeengel. Jetzt können wir noch einen Schneeengel machen oder mal Schneeballschlacht. Und der hat dann so einen Brief geschrieben und das ist wirklich sehr sehr dramatisch, und der letzte Satz war, und wenn jemand meine Leiche und diesen Brief findet, dann sagt meiner Frau, dass ich sie liebe. Und das Letzte, was er gemacht hat, ist, er hat das Wort Frau durchgeschrieben und Witwe drüber geschrieben. What the fuck? Holy fucking crap. Moment mal kurz, aber es ist faktisch falsch. Wenn du es noch schreiben kannst, ist sie noch keine Witwe.
In dem Moment, in dem es jemand liest, ist es richtig. Aber wie krass das Mindset, dass der verstanden hat, dass seine Frau bald so Witw wird.
Okay, hey, wo habt ihr Bock, wo habt ihr, die Bahn, kommt zu spät, die Bahn, die streichen.
Es stand nirgendwo Comedy drauf, weil sie, guck mal genau nach, wir haben mit Anwälten gesprochen, es stand nirgendwo, dass er die ganze Zeit lachenachen müssen. Die sieben Verträgen, die ihr unterschrieben habt, auf dem Weg hier erstatten, nirgendwo was von lachen. Oh, das ist auf dem Sitzchen, dann kommt das Mikrofon plötzlich so nach. Was mich wahnsinnig ärgert, und da meine ich euch, liebe Journalisten, die anwesend sind, nicht bei tausend Leuten, mit Journalisten, wo ist er der Weser-Kurier? Aber ich habe dann, vorher kam dann irgendwer auf mich zu und sagte mir, Stefan, wir fragen dich mal, weil Florentin will es eh nicht machen, wir brauchen eine Pressemitteilung, okay, für die Dinge halt so Begleitschreiben, die man bei der Tour halt dabei legt und dann können das Presseleute halt aufgreifen. Niemand greift mein Presseschreiben auf, niemand, da steht das irre Comedy-Duo, Florentin und Stefan wollen es nochmal wissen. Diesen Satz habe ich noch nirgendwo gelesen, ausser auf unserer Website. Wir wollen es noch mal wissen. Das irre Comedy-Duo. Was wollen wir wissen genau? Was müssen wir vor allem tun, um als irres Comedy-Duo bezeichnet zu werden? Das würde ich gerne mal schaffen. Keine Ahnung. Irres Comedy-Duo. Gib den Satz mal so bei Google ein und guck mal, was dabei rauskommt. Vielleicht kommen wir tatsächlich, was mir da lustig wäre. Oder Erkan und Stefan. Die nächste Tour komplett in der Antarktis. Einfach nur. Ich habe mir übrigens gedacht, der Stefan von Erkan und Stefan, der ist ja in der SPD. Der heisst ja nicht Stefan. Der heisst Florian, Florian Simbeck. Weird, das ist so, als ob dein Hund Michael nennt. Moment. Naja, ich sag nur. Naja, okay, ich sehe deinen Punkt. Es ist so slightly off. Also warum nennst du dich um? Ja, wie heisst er denn? Ja, wie heisst er denn? Markus. Markus. Okay. Markus, komm mal kurz her. Hi Markus. Achso, du meinst, du lebst ja mit dem Namen Stefan, also musst du sagen, sich als Künstlername Stefan zu nennen, ist eine gute Idee. Seltsam, warum sollte man das tun? Es ist ein normaler Name. Es ist einer von vier, zehn normalen Namen, die es gibt, die sich nicht auszeichnen. Ich dachte mir, als ich letztens Politik gesehen habe, also dieses Politikzeug, was da so passiert. So wie Leute, die Afrika als Land bezeichnen. Ich habe neulich Politik gesehen, läuft manchmal auf Phoenix.
Die sind jetzt in der siebten Staffel und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich habe bei der fünften die Figuren schon irgendwie nicht mehr auseinanderbekommen.
Die letzte Staffel Tagesschau war mega, mega. So geile Cliffhanger, drückt der auf den Knopf oder nicht? Das ist dieser irre Asiate. Was macht der? Man weiss es nicht.
Und immer wenn es um die SPD geht, denke ich mir immer so, ja wen wählen die jetzt, wollen die die Farbe wechseln? Ich checke es aber nicht genau. Und dann denke ich mir immer so, irgendwann kommt der Punkt, wo Florian Simbeck kommt und die ganze SPD rettet. Ich glaube, es ist an dem Zeitpunkt, wo nur noch er die SPD retten kann, wo er jetzt krill kommt und alle sagen, krass, den kenne ich. Der war früher lustig, vielleicht ist er jetzt klug. Das ergibt Sinn. Ich glaube schon.
Ist das bei der Anstalt oder was ist das hier für ein...
Ich versuche mich ja lang...
Ich will aus dieser Politikecke raus, Lomitien. Ich will lieber in die Weihnachtsecke.
Das war schön, als wir in der Weihnachtsecke...
Oh Leute, diese Verzögerung ist echt...
Der Mann am Lichtschalter hat auch schon Netflix angemacht.
Vor allem in der Probe kamen wir auf diese lustige Idee, die wir fanden, und dann haben wir danach mal den Test gemacht und ein paar von Weihnachten gesagt.
Und da oben ging das Licht nicht an. Wir haben dann wütend hoch geguckt und dann riefen wir eine Stimme aus dem Off, ja, Leute.
Und das war das erste Wort, was wir gewechselt haben. Wir haben die ganze Zeit nur gesagt, kann da jemand das Licht anmachen, dann ging es halt an und dann hört man so aus dem Off, Leute, und das war das erste Wort, was wir gewechselt haben. Wir haben die ganze Zeit gesagt, kann da jemand das Licht anmachen, dann ging es halt an und dann hört man sowas oft, oh Leute, oh Leute, man muss echt sagen, in diesem Ort, Leute, ist so viel drin, erstens, ich habe gerade viel wichtigeres zu tun, als das scheiß Licht anzumachen, zweitens, ihr nervt, drittens, hier war letztens Bill Burr, was macht ihr hier? Ich glaube, das ist mein Wort des Jahres, Leute, Leute, Leute, das ist eigentlich immer sehr gut, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr absurd. Es ist die grösste Halle, die wir jemals bestätigt haben. Wir haben hier Bill Burr gesehen, es ist sehr verrückt. Wir haben unten in unserer ... Wir haben da gesessen, Ziggern. Wir haben da, genau, da wo du sitzt. Du musst dich nicht umdrehen, genau du. Genau du, genau du. Und wir haben im Backstage gab es Bananen, vielleicht haben wir eine Banane nicht gegessen, die Bilbo auch schon nicht gegessen hat. Das wäre so krass. Hey Leute, das war mir zu fancy, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das war mir zu fancy, weil wenn man da geht ins Klo und ich habe nicht gefunden, ich bin diesen Luxus nicht gewohnt, nach den Papiertüchern zu suchen. Weil normalerweise hängen die halt in diesem hässlichen Plastikteil. Du bist so verwöhnt, du bist so auch loben. Und dann zieht man das raus. Nee, und hier ist es in so einem, schaut so ein Fitzel, hat es aussieht wie so eine Zahnbürste, so ein Fitzel schaut aus diesem Marmor raus. Und dann, ich habe erst gar nicht gecheckt, was das ist. Und dann war das das Papiertuch, wo man da mit nassen Fingern so ran, ich glaube, Luxus ist primär anstrengend, ehrlich gesagt. Mit nassen Fingern muss man dann so rumfriemeln, hat dann plötzlich dieses Ding da in der Hand. Warum ändert man was, was funktioniert? Warum muss man das anders machen? Du kannst einfach an Papier ziehen und dann hast du Papier in der Hand. Warum muss man dieses Prinzip verändern? Das macht keinen Sinn. Vor allem, ich war letztens bei jemandem zu Gast, der hatte ein Handbidee. Waschbecken. Jetzt möchte ich euch. Was ist ein Handbidee? Jetzt ergibt das viel Sinn. Stimmt. Erstmal Bidee hat sich nicht so hundertprozentig. Natürlich ist ein Handbidee, das ist so eine Art Super Soaker, die du halt aber, also nicht ganz, es ist halt so eine Das habe ich mir schon gedacht, das ist so eine Gummi-Gelübde, wo du selber Wasser reintun musst und dann kannst du es so rausspritzen, aber es hat so einen langen Stiel und dann so einen Stiel nach oben. Ja, eine Po-Dusche, eine Hand-Po-Dusche zum Mitnehmen, eine Reise-Po-Dusche zum Reisen. Genau, und ich habe diesen Gegenstand von vorne bis hinten nicht verstanden, weil du kannst ja nicht erst auf die Toilette gehen und dann merken, oh, jetzt muss ich sie befüllen mit Wasser, ich stehe nochmal auf, gehe zum Handbidee, fülle sie, du musst also vorausplanen, wer benutzt das? Aber ganz kurz, da stehst du da an einem öffentlichen Waschbecken und füllst ein Handbidee, die Leute erleben die denken auch, was ist sein Plan? Aber das ist so der klassische Moment. Du kommst aus dem Flugzeug mit so einem gefüllten Handbidee. Und wenn Leute lachen, machst du die nass. Man füllt gerade sein Handbidee und guckt rüber und da steht ein anderer, der auch gerade sein Handbidee füllt. Man weiss einfach, ja, man guckt sich an und macht, ja, und dann schnell Hände waschen, Ja, schnell Hände waschen, weil, ja. Ja, das ist weird, ich verstehe nicht genau, aber das lag dann da offen rum, oder was, das Bild die Hand. Es lag so zum Angebot, vor allem, es gibt ja auch. Wie Angebot. Also es lag da so rum, wie so ein Sudoku-Heft. Ja, wenn du in eine andere Wohnung kommst, ist es ja so ein bisschen Einladung in meine Welt. Denk bitte so, wie ich denke. Bei mir ist es geh wieder raus schnell. Weil mir alles sagt, nee du bleibst hier nicht, es gibt nur ein Kissen. Ja, aber ich zum Beispiel hätte, wenn jemand bei mir zu Gast kommt, ich hätte den Impuls, Dinge zu verstecken, aber ich weiß ja nicht genau, was ich verstecken soll, wo bin ich anders als andere, man weiß es ja nicht genau, man weiß ja nicht, wo man sich von anderen unterscheidet. Zum Beispiel war ich mal bei jemandem zu Hause, der hatte einfach direkt vor der Toilette einen sogenannten Scheissschemel stehen. Das ist so ein Schemel, den stellt man vor die Toilette, damit man ein bisschen erhöht ist. Ich liebe Scheissschemel. Und ich fand es einfach krass, dass der auch einfach so dachte, ja klar. So, und der geht wahrscheinlich in andere Wohnungen und denkt sich, irgendwas fehlt hier. Ja, wie mir. Ich kann es nicht benennen, aber irgendwas fehlt hier. Der macht sich darüber lustig, dass du es nicht hast vielleicht. Wahrscheinlich, ja. Aber wofür ist es denn gut, dass der Winkel ein anderer ist? Der Winkel ist dann glaube ich besser. Der Winkel ist doch gut. Sind nicht die Klos schon darauf ausgelegt, dass der Winkel gut ist? Ich glaube, der menschliche Körper hat sich tatsächlich noch nicht dem der Toilette angepasst. Der braucht noch den Schemel. So ist es schwimmt. Vielleicht kannst du ihn besser sauber machen. Nee, Nee, ich glaube das ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was weiss ich denn, wo ist unser Urologe? Da. Ja, da musst du dir libern. Okay, das ist klar. Dann komm mal runter. 16 Jahre Medizinstudium für ein, das hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt. Ich bin kein Urologe, habe ich in einem GIF gesehen. So, und ohne Scheiss, ich gehe lieber zu einem GIF-Arzt, zu einem guten GIF-Arzt als in der Rechnung. Sie sind eingestellt. Also, um den Enddarm ist ein Muskel, und wenn man sich halt so hinsetzt, wie man es in der ... Das ist schon alles in einem GIF drin, oder was? Schickt das GIF in unsere Telegram-Gruppe, dann haben wir alle einen schönen Abend. Da guck dir nicht rein. Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi. Ihr habt mich gar nicht lieb. Da hat jemand das Mikrofonrecht verspielt. Wer kritisiert, fliegt raus, mein Lieber. Naja, das können wir rechtlich nicht, aber... Guck dir gar nicht rein. Dieser Mensch, der Arme. Aber das ist schon, um den Muskel zu entspannen. Das ist glaube ich die, sonst rückt er den Darm, natürlich, ab. Klar, und deswegen, wir haben gemerkt, dass was nicht funktioniert in unserem Leben, wir wussten nicht was fehlt, jetzt wissen wir, na, Scheisschemel fehlt. Der SS. Ab jetzt im Merch-Shop habt ihr eure Augen offen, falls ihr einen wollt. Da können auch so kleine Geschichten drauf. Da so ein Display, so ein iPad mit drin. Da haben Sudoku rein. Ja, ein schönes Sudoku. Ein sehr spezielles Klo, was Florantina hat. Niemand will bei dir aufs Klo gehen. Ich habe die beste Klo-Diktüre, aber ich sage nicht, welche es ist. Ja, super. Dafür sind wir alle hier, um zu hören, was nicht bei denen in der Wohnung liegt. Was ich gar nicht mag, ist, wenn Leute rausgehen bei Veranstaltungen und den Namen der Stadt rufen. Das, was wir die ersten zwei Minuten gemacht haben. Köln, hey Köln! Mir ist mir aufgefallen, ich war nie bei einer Veranstaltung, aus dessen Stadt ich kam.
Ich war hier in Köln bei Green Day und Green hat gerufen, hey Köln, was geht ab? Und ich habe natürlich gerufen, yay, aber tief in meinem Herzen dachte ich mir, hätte ich lieber gerufen, ja, ich komme aus der Ecke bei Dortmund eigentlich immer, wuhu! Ich bin nicht repräsentativ, was den Launepegel angeht, coole Musik! Und Billy Joe Armstrong, okay, ich spiele American Idiot, okay? Aber das war schon, es ist nie cool eigentlich. Deswegen, also niemand von euch wahrscheinlich, ich sag mal so 20 Prozent kommen aus Köln, oder? Die wenigsten kommen wirklich aus Köln. Das ist immer so, mal kurz mal einen Applaus fest, wer kommt aus Köln wirklich, aus Köln, Köln. Können wir zur Referenz kurz alle klatschen, damit wir wissen, ob das jetzt leiser war? Ich weiss nicht, was es davon entscheiden soll, aber schon eine Menge. Vor allem, ich bin ja ein internationaler Typ, muss ich ja mal sagen, also dieses ganze lokale Zeug interessiert mich nicht. Wie oft warst du schon mal im Ausland? Ich bin online unterwegs, mein Horizont ist der Breitband, das Breitband-Internet. Obwohl ich wirklich, und das habe ich gerade gemerkt, nicht auch nur im Ansatz weiss, was Breitband bedeutet. Keine Ahnung, kein Plan. Schmalband gibt es das auch, kann man sich irgendwo das ankreuzen und alle haben sich für Breitband entschieden. Und was ist Glasfaser? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ist Glasfaser, alles was mit Glas? Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Und wenn du online was bestellst aus Amerika oder so, musst du dir eine Stadt eingeben, aber die nehmen kein Ö an. Also du sagst dann Köln. Okay, reden wir jetzt darüber. Und die Leute nehmen kein Ö an und ich habe locker schon bestimmt viele Sachen nach Köln geschickt. Einfach das kleine verschlafene Dorf Köln in der Nähe von Brott. Und da wird alles hingeschickt, was ich bestelle aus Vietnam und so. Tragisch. Die Welt muss enger zusammenrücken, die Welt, wir brauchen mehr Solidarität zwischen den Ländern, oder? Nee, nee, kann ja auch nein sein, ihr müsst ja nicht eigentlich selber, weint doch mal. Ich fand's so weird, dass bei dem ganzen Brexit-Kram, ja, das ist die grosse Politik. Weihnachten und Politik. Und hier ist Anne Wille meine Damen und Herren. Da haben alle immer auf die Alten geschimpft, dass die Alten wählen durften. Leute, ich stelle die Demokratie in Frage. Warum? Naja, die gehören ja auch dazu. Warum müssen die aufhören zu wählen, nur weil sie bald sterben?
Ausser aus dem Grund. Was ist der Grund?
Ihr braucht zumindest drei Gründe für diesen Antrag. Ist schon seltsam, oder?
Ja, stimmt schon. Aber es dreht sich so ein bisschen um. Früher wurde die Jugend gehasst, und jetzt hassen alle die Alten.
Alle Alten zumindest. Alle Alten gleich.
Stimmt. Aber ich meine, die nicht wählen dürfen, wenn man bald stirbt, was ist mit schwer kranken Menschen? So jetzt einfach mal, jetzt haue ich meine Meinung raus, jetzt haue ich meine Meinung raus, warum haben Kinder dann nicht zwei Stimmen, weil die lange leben, warum dürfen Kinder nicht würfeln, wie viele Stimmen sie haben. Ich frage mich, ob Hitler auch als Comedyprogramm angefangen hat, er hat sich so herangetastet, er hat sich so herangetastet. Ich frag mich gerade, was wenn die Juden einfach nie mehr da wären. Und dann lachen und so, er sagt, das ist okay. Okay, und dann hat er sich langsam vorgetraut und dann immer mehr. Ich glaube so fängt es an, mit Comedy. Schlechtes Comedy. Man kann ja die alten Leute auch ganz einfach davon abhalten zu wählen. Du kannst ja einfach vor dem Wahllokal so ganz viele Wärter so original verstreuen oder die so wegleiten. Wegleiten in so eine Müllpresse. Da laufen die alle weg. Oder, oder, und das voll gelacht. Oder man stellt die Wahlurne an so ein Ende von so einem Ninja-Borrier-Parcours und so lässt man nur die Fitten, die Fitten können wählen. Ja. Willst du das wirklich, dass das so sein soll?
Hey, ich habe vier Kilo abgenommen, in zwei Wochen habe ich vier Kilo abgenommen.
Von?
Hundert. Ich habe es nicht ertragen. Ich habe diese dreistellige Zahl nicht ertragen.
Und dann gehst du ins Fitnessstudio und du siehst andere Leute, die auch die dreistellige Grenze überschritten haben.
Und man grüsst dich so wie Busfahrer.
Ja.
Weil man sieht sich so und denkt, stay in there.
Es gibt nur diese zwei Leute, die im Fitnessstudio sind, die zwei Arten Leute. Leute, die die Dreiergrenze überschritten haben und Leute, die fertig sind. Leute, die nicht mehr da sein müssten. Ich will denen immer sagen, Leute, du passt Muskeln, du siehst gut aus, geh nach Hause und guck einen Film oder so. Warum bist du denn hier, es ist Freitagsabends, 20 Uhr, ja, das ist die Zeit, wo ich ins Fitnessstudio gehe. Und warum bist du du musst hier nicht sein das bringt auch nichts mehr das ist wie man so eine fertige waffel in waffeleisen ja so das ist bringt nichts und es wird auch schlechter die waffel wird brauner und diese typen werden irgendwann wächst ein anderer mensch aus denen heraus habt ihr mal gesehen da haben die so einen dicken nacken das ist doch auch nicht mehr schön es sieht aus ob so ein zweiter mensch aus dem anderen rauskommt der den anderen ste steuern kann. So koko bei der mehr. Wie bei Avatar diese Exoskelette, die man sich anziehen kann. Ich finde, je breiter Bodybuilder sind, desto mehr sehen die aus wie so jemand, der ein Exoskelette steuert. Ja, das stimmt. Die und dann die andere Gruppe, wo man sich anschaut und genau weiß, wir versuchen so wenig Zeit wie möglich hier in diesem Raum zu verbringen. Wir wollen so schnell es geht wieder weg und wir suchen dann irgendwelche Strohhalmen, die wir erreichen können, um dann schnell wieder gehen zu können.
Kaum bist du auf 99,9 macht's gut Leute ab zum Strand einfach schön Bikini hat und ab zum Strand. Ja, vor allem dann, ich habe jetzt eine komische App, wo man halt überall trainieren kann. Du hast keine Ausreden mehr. Nee, genau. Und das Problem ist aber, weil mir ist gar nicht klar gewesen, wie sehr ich dieses überteuerte, schlechte, stinkende Fitnessstudio, was ich mal hatte, wo ich dann mal regelmäßig war, kennengelernt habe. Also, wie lange ich mich da auch daran gewöhnt habe, weil dann weisst du, wo die ganzen Sachen sind und so, ich kenne mich ja nicht aus. Ich weiß ja nicht, wofür dieses Gerät ist, wo dann noch mehr Gewichte dranhängen und wo man irgendwie sich so reinklemmen muss und dann muss man den und dann, weiss ich nicht, sieht man besser aus danach, nach einem Jahr. Weiß ich nicht, kenne ich mich nicht mehr aus. Also lasse ich mir das vom Trainer zeigen. Und jetzt bin ich in ganz vielen Fitnessstudios, wo ich nicht mehr weiß. Und leider sehen diese Geräte, die sind nicht genormt. Es sieht nicht immer, ein Stuhl sieht immer aus wie ein Stuhl, den erkenne ich. Aber dann sieht diese komische, wo man diese Kniebeugen mitmacht, die sehen nicht immer so aus. Und dann stehe ich, dann laufe ich in diese neuen Fitnessstudios und habe immer so ein Handtuch in der Hand und so meine Getränkflasche. Und dann will ich ja auch nicht auffallen. Du laufst nicht so entspannt. Du laufst nicht so lässig und entspannt. Ich lauf betont entspannt. Betont entspannt? Ja, um nicht aufzufallen, weil alle laufen so durch das Fitnessstudio. Und dann stehe ich vor diesen Geräten und denke mir, keine Ahnung, das ist, habe ich noch nie in meinem Leben gesehen, wo muss man dann und dann fasse ich so an und denke mir, weil ich will wissen, was kann sich bewegen an diesem Gerät. Und dann schubst sich Dinge so an und dann merke ich, okay das ist eine Beinpresse, ich habe zu etwas ganz anderes gehalten und dann gehe ich wieder weg, hier ist ein riesen Viech auf der Bühne, um den Anschein zu erwecken, als ob ich nicht gerade zu diesem Gerät müsste. Es ist ein bisschen wie ein Museum eigentlich, wenn man auch so interessiert rumläuft, kurz stehen bleibt und dann nach wirklich niedrigstmöglicher Zeit wieder weggehen. Und ich habe vor allem da, wo ich mal war für 20 Minuten, stand an den Geräten, welcher Muskel trainiert wurde. Und ich gucke mir diesen Muskel an und denke mir so, brauche ich den, brauche ich wirklich den, der so in der Mitte des Rückens hochgeht? Eigentlich nicht, oder dem Urzimmer brauche ich den. Und dann zum nächsten hier der, nee, der passt auch. Es ist so ein bisschen auch so fühlen und das, was du fühlst, brauchst du auch nicht mehr. Das reicht dir dann auch. Ja, wo du gerade sagst, ist wie im Museum, warum nicht einfach so ein Lexikonartikel, weil man starrt oft an die gleiche Stelle, weil man diese gleichen Bewegungen macht. Einfach schön so ein Lexikonartikel. Weiß nicht. Dreissichjähriger Krieg. So, und dann müssen die beim Pumpen das lesen. Wird das nicht genial? Oder sie dürfen erst aufhören, wenn Sie so ein Quiz beantwortet haben. Oh, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Vielleicht eine richtig gute Idee. Wer hat das Geld erfunden? Wie lange war der Dreissigjährige Krieg? Wie viel kostet dieses Gerät? Geld, das war auch wirklich seltsam. Da bin ich da reingelaufen. Und es war im gleichen Gebäude wie das Fresenius-Institut. Und für mich sind Fitnessstudios, wenn man vom Land kommt, sind es Gebäude. Das sind die Gebäude. Und dann fährt man da hin und dann ist man da und dann geht man rein. Wie ein Kino. Leider war es aber, das war kein Gebäude, es war halt ein Bürotrakt. Und dann bin ich hochgelaufen, ein paar Treppen und konnte mich dann anmelden.
Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, da sind die Umkleiden, da war ich fertig mit der Umkleide und dann bin ich rausgegangen, aber wo waren jetzt die Geräte? Und dann war ich plötzlich in diesem Flur von dem Fresenius-Institut, weil das halt da so ist, da ist halt das Fitnessstudio und neben mir war so ein Typ mit dem Anzug und Ich war am Aktenkoffer und ich stand da halt mit meinem zu kurzen Adidas-Shirt und dachte mir so, ja, ha ha ha, und dachte mir, was macht der jetzt, der wird jetzt nicht die Beinpresse gehen, der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich arbeiten gehen, und da habe ich es nicht gefunden. Die brauchen vielleicht so Testobjekte oder so, einfach so Leute, die in die Arme laufen, aber apropos zu kurze Hose, möchtest du den Zuschauern nicht was sagen von der letzten Live-Show? Sorry. Das klang jetzt nicht ehrlich. Oh, es tat mir so leid. Also ganz ernsthaft tut es mir total leid. Ich habe letzte... Puh, ist es nicht einfach. Ist es nicht einfach. Bei der letzten Aufzeichnung in Hamburg kam es zu einem Vorfall, auf den ich nicht stolz bin, auf den das ganze Team des Podcast-Oboos nicht stolz ist.
Ich hatte ein riesen, riesen Loch in meiner Hose. Ein riesen Loch. Und das Problem ist, ich wusste zum Teil, dass es existiert. Man hat eine Ahnung, es ist eine Ahnung, man spürt es so halb. Das Problem war, das war das Sekundärloch. Also, ich erklär es gut. Man merkt dann manchmal, wenn man sitzt und man richtet die Hose, merkt man, okay, das ist nicht in Ordnung. Vor allem, ich hatte so eine weisse Boxerbriefs an dem Tag an und es war eine schwarze Hose. Also man hat wirklich, es hat Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen. Und dann habe ich an dem Tag aber auch schon gesehen, okay, da ist ein kleines Loch. Das war aber nur ganz klein, das war nicht so schlimm. Und deswegen habe ich nicht weiter geschaut. Aber darunter klaffte einfach diese Höhle. Und ich denke mir, ihr seht das ja, es kommt Licht von vorne, es gucken, in Hamburg waren es glaube ich 600 Leute, gucken einfach dahin und ich sitze die ganze Zeit so da und man hat die ganze Zeit in meinen Schritt gucken können. Ja, als wäre es Absicht. Es könnte nicht mehr wie Absicht aussehen. Du machst einfach den hier so, wie so ein Hund, der einfach so, du kommst nach Hause und der Hund legt sich so hin und wir wissen alle, das ist okay, da starren wir jetzt die nächsten 40 Minuten an. Mit seinem Schritt und dein Gesicht ist es einfach scheißegal und erkennt dann nichts. So saß ich dann die ganze Zeit und dann habe ich schon gemerkt, so am Merchstand habe ich schon gemerkt, die Stimmung war schwierig. Und dann kamen wir Leute und kamen dann zu mir und haben dann so ins Ohr geflüstert, du hast einen Riesenlaut. Das ist eine Riesenlaut. Danke, dass du mir das nach der eineinhalb stündigen Show schaffst. Die ganze Reihe hat die ganze Zeit und darauf geachtet. Falls du dich fragst, warum niemand gelacht hat über euch. Ja. Also nochmal von dieser Stelle aus, grosses Sorry. Wir brauchen, glaube ich, ein Codeword. Ich glaube, wenn irgendwas mit der Garderobe nicht stimmt, brauchen wir ein Codeword, dass einer das reinschreit, damit wir einfach wissen, was los ist. Wir brauchen einfach wirklich, wir brauchen mutige Zivilcourage auch unter unseren Zuschauern, die uns darauf hinweisen, dass wir nicht so ins Messer laufen. Okay, Vorschläge? Was ist das beste Code-Word? Was wird niemals bei uns im Podcast fallen? Welches Wort? Lustig, ja. Alles klar. Okay. Oh, okay. Die Telegram-Gruppe meldet sich zu Wort. Was? Oh, das war ich abgemacht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Sehr schön. Ihr gebt das Zepter gerade an die falschen Leute. Sagen wir mal, welches Wort Kramp-Karrenbauer, bin ich mir sicher, wird nicht fallen in diesem Podcast. Das stimmt, aber es könnte natürlich auch eine politische Parole sein, Wenn jemand hier ein großer Fan ist, könnte man das verwechseln. Ich glaube, bei den Franzosen war es ja so, dass irgendwie beim Ersten Weltkrieg oder so hatten die auch ein Codeword, dass sie sagen, wenn sie angreifen. Und das Codeword war einfach Schnurrbart. Das Codeword war Schnurrbart. Das heißt, während die französischen Soldaten über die Schützengräben gerannt sind zum Angriff, Schnurrbart, Mustache, einfach so, die Deutschen so, wow, okay, Karl, du hast keinen Bock mehr. Aber wie problematisch, wenn du mit deinem Kumpel irgendwo im Frontgraben stehst und der hat so ein Stück Nudeln in seinem Schnurrbart und du willst ihm sagen, du hast da was in deinem, was wo denn, nee, in deinem, du hast da was in deinem Schnörres. Lass uns Schnurrbart sagen einfach. Wenn irgendwas in Zukunft sein sollte, ruft so laut, es geht Schnörres oder Schnurrbart. Weswegen nochmal? Falls irgendein Defekt der Garderobe feststellbar ist. Achso, okay. Na gut, jetzt kann es kommen, dass es jetzt reinruft, weil wir so aussehen, wie wir aussehen. Gut, also dann als Gag sagt ihr Schnurrbart, aber wenn ihr es wirklich ernst meint, dann sagt ihr Schnörres, okay? Schnurrbart-Gag, Schnörres-Ernst, alles klar? Sehr gut, darauf kann man sich verstehen. Zwei Nicken, der Rest ist überhaupt nicht mehr anwesend, sehr gut, sehr schön. Der Rest hört Gäste-Lisse-Geister-Bahn auf einmal. Wir hatten kurz überlegt, ob wir einfach eine alte Folge Podcast abspielen. Irgendwann war es. Oder einfach so das Transkript, dass wir wirklich alles auswendig lernen. Ich will einfach die Bühne ein bisschen nutzen. Ich will die Bühne einfach ein bisschen nutzen. Ja komm, wir machen ein bisschen. Dass wir einfach eine komplette alte Folge noch mal eins zu eins abschreiben, auswendig lernen und dann performen. Und da brauchen wir auch ein Codeodeword, falls das jemand bemerkt, dass wir das tun. Okay, finde ich gut. Was machst du eigentlich zu Weihnachten? Ich habe auch noch nicht herausgefunden, was ich mir wünschen soll. Das ist mittlerweile wirklich erdrückende Last, dass ich mir was wünschen soll. Aber es ist ein schöner Moment, wenn man merkt, man braucht nichts mehr. Du wünschst, ach komm Stefan, jetzt holst du es aber auch. Die Hose ist heil. Jetzt genießt es aber auch. Das hat noch niemand jemals gemacht, oder? Er hat sich umgekehrt auf Barhocker gesetzt, weil es keinen Sinn ergibt, vor allem vielleicht. Coole Lehrer haben das mal bei uns gemacht. Die coole Lehrer haben sich immer rückwärts und dann, na erzähl mal, worüber will du heute sprechen, ne? Bei uns gab es einen Lehrer, der hatte ein Sitzkissen. Der hatte immer, kurze Sau überhaupt, der kam einfach rein und hatte mein Sitzkissen, hat es auf den Stuhl gelegt, sich draufgesetzt und er hat es einfach regelmäßig vergessen in dem Klassenzimmer, wo er davor war. Das heißt, es war immer die schlimmste Aufgabe aller Zeiten, wenn er dann so sagt, so, hier, Paul, hol mal meinen Sitzkissen, da hat kein Trauel in der Klasse so. Irgendjemand geht einfach und muss dann diese Sitzkissen von dem Lehrer aus dem anderen Klassenzimmer holen, ganz schrecklich. Ein Kollege von mir hat auch so ein Sitzkissen. Das wappelt halt so. Und man muss dann, man kann Sitz dann halt gerade. Aber ich denke mir, also entweder du bist jetzt die letzten 20 Jahre deines Lebens so gerade oder du hast davor halt 50 Jahre auf einem peinlichen Kissen gesessen? Ja, das stimmt. Was ist jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob das besser ist, auf diesem scheiß Gymnastikball, den Kollegen von dir immer wegschießen, ob das besser ist, sich so zum Gespött zu machen oder einfach die letzten 20 Jahre einfach ein bisschen geduckt gehen. Mein Gott. Ich weiß auch noch, dass wir bei uns in der Schule, wir hatten eine moderne Klasse. Alle Klassen DDR, irgendwie Altnazizeug, noch irgendwie kein Problem, und dann gab es die eine moderne Klasse. Und die haben alle besucht. Da wurden alle fünften Klassen dann zu denen ins Klassenzimmer gebracht, weil die, die mal gezeigt haben, so der Mensch von morgen, so, das sind jetzt die modernst ausgestattete Klasse bei uns in der Schule, und alle sind super krass. Und diese Modernität bestand darin, dass sie diese Bälle hatten. Das war alles, das waren die moderne und alle hatten die Bälle und es sah einfach so, es sah so dermassen albern aus, wenn einfach so, so, wer hat den ersten Weltkrieg verloren und alle einfach so, niemand meldet sich. Diese Geräuschkulisse, was ist mit Thomas Buddenbroek, und das steht auch nicht mehr aus der letzten Reihe. Ich habe jetzt nicht verstanden, wie konnten die Nazis die Macht ergreifen. Vor allem, du kannst ja auch als Lehrer niemanden wirklich jetzt fertig machen, der gerade so wippt eigentlich. Du wirst niemals erfolgreich werden, du wirst niemals erfolgreiches Leben haben. Du hast eine fünfte wippendes Arschloch. Nee, kann man nicht, das stimmt schon. Das stimmt, das geht einfach nicht. Ich habe mir überlegt, was ich mir wünschen soll dieses Jahr. Ich bin auf nichts Gutes gekommen und ich weiß nicht, ob man sich Geld wünschen kann. Ich dachte mir aber, das Geld... Ich hasse Geld als Wunsch, es ist so uncool. Es ist so uncool, ich weiß nicht, aber ich dachte mir, vielleicht könnte man es irgendwie aufpeppen. Ich weiß doch, dass ich... Ich hatte keine Ahnung, was ich meinen Eltern schenken sollte und habe denen eines Jahres Geld geschenkt. Was wirklich das Dümmste ist, was man überhaupt machen kann, wenn du dir als Kind schenkst du deiner Mutter 25 Euro. Und er muss dann sagen, okay. Ja, vor allem Sie gibt dir ja wahrscheinlich auch Geld, 50, und dann sollen wir es direkt in den letzten kleinen, können wir es direkt wechseln. Ich habe schon deine 50 mitgerechnet, deswegen gebe ich dir jetzt ein Hunderter, du bist aber nur 50. Ich hatte an dem Tag kein Geld, ich musste es von meiner Mutter leihen, es war einfach ganz schrecklich. Aber ich dachte mir auch, ich kann meiner Mutter nicht nur Geld schenken. Ich kann ja nicht irgendwie aus meinem Kleingeldeimer zwei Hände Kleingeld geben. Sehr klein auch, sehr viel Kupfergeld. Ja, weil ich dich lieb habe, kriegst du drei Kilo Geld. Und dann habe ich mich entschieden, aus dem Geld was zu basteln. Und dann habe ich wirklich so aus dem Geld, aus den Scheinen so so einen Skifahrer gebastelt und habe das so mit unendlich viel Tesafilmen auf dem Zettel geklebt. Dass man nicht mehr erkennt, dass es Geld ist und die Eltern denken, dass man so einen Skifahrer geschehen. Ja, man erkennt nicht, dass es Geld ist und allein um das Geld rauszuholen, hat man es wahrscheinlich dreimal zerrissen. Ich glaube, meine Eltern haben das so ein bisschen in den Müll geworfen. Aber ich sag Ihnen einfach nicht, wenn ich dachte, vor allem, wenn ich dachte mir als Kind immer, dass Geld sehr schön ist. Geld ist schön. Ich finde unsere Euroscheine sind sehr schön. Da kann man auch mal einen Applaus geben. Um verhaltener Applaus. Wir sind nicht Eurofans. Aber auch was für eine abgefahrene Aktion da ja, da sind ja Phantasiegebäude drauf, ne, auf den Euroscheinen. Was ist los? Wie gibt's nicht so? Weil man, also mein Vater hat mir das erklärt, ein bisschen ausgezogen hat mein Vater alles erklärt, man hat gesagt so, naja, wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel das Brandenburger Tor drauf wär, denn wär ja Dänemark wütend, dass kein dänisches Gebäude drauf ist. Also macht man irgendein komplettes Quatschgebäude drauf, weil es scheißegal ist. So macht man den Monopolymann drauf. Genau. Aber warum genau, also die Brücke existiert doch, diese Brücke, die ich gerade vor Augen habe. Sind sie auch nur Brücken? Ne, die existieren tatsächlich nicht. Die sind einfach Fantasiegebäude, da einfach damit irgendwas drauf ist. Ist wirklich so. Das widerspricht ja auch niemand. Sonst hätten ja Leute widersprochen. Ich dachte mir vor allem, man hätte es ja auch mit Leuten machen können. Weil auf den Mark scheinen waren immer Leute drauf, was ich gucke. Einfach so Phantasiemenschen, damit niemand sagt, das aber ein Däne, haha, wir Dänen oder die scheisse Dänen wieder hier, sondern einfach Phantasiemenschen. Die Frommeyer von oben drüber. Das ist die, die auf dem Euro scheinen, einfach mit einem Passanten anquatscht. Fände ich nicht so schlecht eigentlich. Ich habe meinem Vater mal eine Maus geschenkt, die er schon besitzt. Ja, hat er sich kurz vorher gekauft und ich dachte mir, eigentlich genial, weil ich bin mir sicher, dass er eine Maus gebraucht hat. So eine Computermaus, sollte man vielleicht zuerst sagen, und dann habe ich die verpackt und ihm geschenkt und habe ihm gesagt, dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich besitze diese Maus schon. Ich besitze diese Maus sogar, wie sie hier, das ist meine Maus.
Ich habe diese Maus benutzt, um dein Geschenk zu bestellen.
Ja genau, dann habe ich gesagt, ich gebe dir das Geld danach, war ein Lacher, aber man kommt halt mit Comedy auch gut durch den Alltag.
Also, oh nein, ich weiß nicht, rückblickend war er vielleicht traurig.
Es ist einfach der schönste, ich mag diesen Umbruch von, wenn Kinder Quatschgeschenke schenken, zu bis sie wirkliche Geschenke schenken müssen. Bis dahin einfach, man klebt drei Nudeln auf dem Blatt Papier und es geht als Geschenke. Eltern freuen sich. Und so, wow, toll, cool. Und dann klebst du halt 40 Euro auf dem Blatt Papier. Ich habe wirklich die meisten Geschenke bestanden daraus, dass ich Dinge auf dem Blatt Papier geklebt habe. Und ich glaube, meine Mutter wusste schon, wenn ich zu ihr kam und sagte, kann ich ein Blatt Papier haben?
Ja, nee, kann ich Tesafilm haben, Robert.
Kann ich Tesafilm haben.
Und sie wusste schon, da ist wieder ein Bullshit-Geschenk im Anmarsch.
Ein komplettes Nonsensgeschenk, einfach.
Was soll das sein?
Ich habe eine grosse Nudel aus kleinen Nudeln geballert.
Okay, danke.
Alles, ciao.
Einfach weg damit. Das finde ich keine schlechte Geste im Weihnachtswohnzimmer. Oh, what the fuck. Das waren sie so nicht. Das ist für mich weihnachtliche Stimmung, einfach grelles Licht von oben. Sehr gut, bei Weihnachtlich ist es nicht angegangen, da ist also die Grenze. Ich habe mir überlegt, dass man, ich dachte ja tatsächlich immer, dass Geld auch das Beste eigentlich sinnvollste Geschenk ist. Es ist nicht romantisch, es ist nicht schön, es ist nicht traditionell, es ist einfach pragmatisch das beste Geschenk, weil du damit kaufen kannst, was du halt brauchst. Aber, dann sitzt du da Weihnachten und er bekommt deine Kupen. Ja, wow, langsam nervt es noch ein bisschen. Ja, vor Vor allem für alle, die die Folge jetzt im Sommer hören. Sie können aber denken, Leute, ist mir scheissegal. Ich hasse Weihnachten. Und die Leute, die auch jetzt immer gut. Wenn das Licht angeht, finde ich nach wie vor lustig, aber dass die alle dann schreien müssen. Oh, Leute, habt ihr Bock auf Franucca? Ja, ne. Leider nicht. Siehst du halt deine Cousine, wie sie dann irgendwie ein cooles, deine kleine Cousine, die so cooles Haus bekommt, wo sie reingehen kann. So ein Haus? Ja, so einen kleinen Geschäftsladen, mit so einem kleinen Telefon und so ein Kaufmannsladen. Ich habe früher einen Kaufmannsladen besessen. Das war das beste Geschenk rückblickend, weil eigentlich, und das ist meine neue Regel, sich was schenken lassen, womit man die Weihnachtstage gut rumbekommt. Ja, sehr gut. Es reicht, Leute, langsam. So, dass man halt, du hast viel Zeit zwischen den Jahren. Ja. Dass du die Zeit gut rumbekommst. Wie viel ungefähr? Ziemlich genau so sieben Tage. Sieben Tage ungefähr, ja. Ja, mit Neujahr vielleicht acht. Tatsächlich, ein Freund von mir hat mittlerweile Kinder und das ist auch so ein Ding, dass man keine Ahnung, wie man mit Kindern umgehen soll. Man kommt ja bei dem zuhause, da hat er auch so einen Kaufladen.
Nicht schütteln. Das ist glaube ich die erste Regel, das ist auch die einzige Regel. Nicht schütteln, sondern rühren. Und dann war ich bei dem zuhause und der hatte so einen Kaufladen und dann spielt man halt... Ach so, aber wenn ich Kaufladen sage, erst mal, was kann er meinen? Wisst ihr, was er meinen könnte? Das ist geil. Aber dann das erste, was du sagst, Kaufladen. Ich denke bei Cousine immer an alte Menschen. Jetzt ist er über 18. Ich habe noch nie eine Cousine unter 18 gesehen. Und dann gehst du halt zu diesem Kind und spielst halt so mit dem so, oh hallo, was haben sie denn in ihrem Laden? Eine Melone, eine Banane, okay, ich hätte gern, hm, was nehme ich denn, was nehme ich denn? Wenn man sagt Lara dir, du bist professioneller Schauspieler, kannst du das ein bisschen einster nehmen? aha, okay. Was nehme ich denn? Nehme ich diese Melone, was kostet die denn? Sieben Euro. Sieben, okay, sieben Euro, okay. Und dann, okay, dann habe ich ihm sieben Euro gegeben und bin mit einer Holzmelone nach Hause gefahren, Sitz im Zug, kam diese scheiß Holzmelone in der Hand, für die die Eltern 20 Euro gezahlt haben. Und ich dachte mir, Kapitalismus funktioniert einfach nicht. Es funktioniert nicht. Das ist der Beweis, glaube ich. Es klappt nicht. Die Melone bis heute. Ich weiß nicht, weil ich irgendwann mal da wieder da bin und sage, so, ich verkaufe dir die Melone zurück für acht Euro, mein Lieber. Und sie sagt, Kapitalismus! Jetzt siehst du mal. Lektionen gelernt. Ich bin Onkel oder der Freund eines Vaters. Man ist zusammen zur Schule gegangen, ich bin der weede Typ, der eine Melode hat. Du bist der weede Onkel, der das T-Shirt in die Joggyhose steckt zu Weihnachten und fragwürdige Thesen am Tisch raushaut. Man muss Kinder auch lange bearbeiten. Ist Jerusalem die Hauptstadt von Israel? So siehst du aus, das ist das Outfit, das ist so anders. So sieht Onkels aus wie der wirde onkel der sieht immer so aus stimmt ja das stimmt aber ich glaube so ein onkel will ich auch werden einfach der immer so ich will der onkel werden der was sagt und alle schauen sie nach unten an meiner zicht so ein bisschen genau das geklimpere mit dem geschirr geht langsam ja ja warum steht auf dem pass eigentlich deutsch und nicht deutschland und also noch Hat niemand die Rouladen angefasst. Warum wird das denn? Man stochert so in der Roulade rum. Fucking Rouladen. Das will ich wer. Wasse Rouladen. Oh, Rouladen. Ist es eigentlich, angenommen, du bestellst in einem richtig guten Restaurant Rouladen, sind da auch diese Bänder drin oder haben die es hingekriegt? Haben die das hingekriegt? Ich glaube, das ist so ein verzweifelter Versuch, der Zahnarztztlobby, Zahnseide so ein bisschen an den Mann zu bringen, weil ich habe nie gecheckt, dass es drin ist und hat es immer im Mund. Es ist immer im Mund. Oh, praktisch. Aber so vielleicht, so funktioniert Essen doch nicht. Angerichtetes Essen funktioniert nicht so. Bei Fisch, okay, dass du Dinge rauskrameln, krümeln musst. Ja. Aber doch nicht bei Rouladen. Ich nicht, kann man das nicht vorher, warum muss es eingeholt sein? Keine Ahnung, kann man auch was reinschieben? Ich weiss nicht genau. Was ich mir letztens überlegt habe, für ein Restaurant, was man machen könnte, und es gibt ja so krasse Restaurants, die irgendwie so Sachen verkaufen, die sonst niemand verkauft. Achtung, gebratene Milbe. So, klingt dumm, klingt dumm, aber denkt nach. Wenn ihr, stellt euch vor, das ist der einzige Laden, dann versteht ihr, warum es dumm klingt. Das ist der einzige Laden, wo man gebratene, aber guck mal, wie alle zuhören, wie ich das Magenknurren. Weil die bezahlt haben. Wir hören mal ganz kurz, wie tausend Leute mit Magenknurren sich anhören. Ja, okay, gut, vielleicht ein bisschen... Und stellt euch vor, ihr bestellt den Milbenlöffel und ihr kriegt einen Löffel gebratene Milben. Das sind zehn Millionen Milben auf einem Löffel, aber ihr wisst, dass es Milben sind. Das ist meine grosse Frage. Ich würde gerne ein Bildband rausbringen mit Dingen, die in ganz viel zum ersten Mal etwas aussehen. Beispiel, ganz viel Bakterien. Wie sieht eine Bakterie aus? Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, man weiss, wie eine Bakterie aussehen. Na gut, aber du weisst, na ja mit bloßem Auge, weisst du nicht, wenn man ganz viele Bakterien zusammenschiebt, bis sie nach was aussehen. Ist Staub auch nichts anderes als Staubmilbenkot? Keine Ahnung, es sind Milben und Erdkot. Und deswegen machen wir Fortschritte an so einem Abend, weil Leute aus dem Publikum reinrufen, nein, das fliegt ja Bullshit in den letzten. Je mehr man weiss, dass man nicht weiss, weiss man auch mehr. Je mehr man weiss, desto unlustiger wird es auch, glaube ich. Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber solange man weiss, was man nicht weiss, ist ja auch schon mal was geholfen. Ich weiss zum Beispiel nicht, wie Melben schmecken. Ja, auch nicht. Stellt euch mal vor, wie schmeckt eine Milbe? Ah, und schon habe ich euch, 38 Euro die Portion. Tja, könnt ihr heute danach direkt vorbeikommen. Schön ein paar Milben braten. Gebratene Milbe. Gebratene Milbe, ich weiss nicht, ist kein Ankommer. Ich glaube, das ist die Zukunft. Ganz kleine Dinge, gebratene Flöhe, aber du hast halt wirklich wahnsinnig viel davon. Ist so ein bisschen das Reis-Prinzip, ne, weil man liebt es. Man liebt es, Reis zu essen, weil es so viel ist. Ist Reis die beste Beilage? Ja, nein, definitiv nicht. Nein? Nein. Was ist die beste Beilage? Was ist die beste Beilage? Das ist nicht uneinlich. Kommes? Kraut? Nudeln? Kartoffeln ist glaube ich die cleverste Antwort, weil es in verschiedenen Zuständen zu einer guten Beilage wird. Kartoffeln, Ofen, Kartoffeln, Gratin. Na gut, aber das zählt nicht zusammen. Pommes, dann Pommes. Bin ich... Auf keinen Fall irgendwas, was man zwischen den Zelten hat. Geil ist Brokkoli, weil es aussieht, als ob du kleine Bäume isst. Das stimmt. Ich glaube, der Urmensch in mir denkt sich, jetzt ist man so ein schöner Baum. Früher haben Menschen ja auch Bäume gefressen. Sie waren ja viel kleiner und Menschen waren grösser. Menschen waren früher viel grösser. Bäume gegessen und Brunnen getrunken und so. Bonsai-Bäume haben wir noch viel zu selten besprochen. Das sind ja einfach oder nicht, kursiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, kleingezüchtete Bäume. Ja, aber wusstest du, dass ich einen Bonsai-Bäum hatte? Ja, ich auch. Ich hatte auch einen und ich war viel zu faul, den zu bearbeiten und am Ende wurde es ein normaler Baum und ich dachte mir so, je, du hast, Mann, ey, du bist rausgekommen aus dem Bonsai-Scheiss. Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich ihn entlassen in die Welt. Und dann macht der Hip-Hop. Komm! Dann macht der Hip-Hop und erzählt von seiner Street-Bonsai-Vergangenheit. Ich war ein Baum wie ihr, ich war ein kleiner Baum. Es gibt ja so Leute, die kaufen dann halt so tausend Fische, um sie ins Meer zu werfen, damit sie frei sind. Und du hast einen Baum gekauft, warst dann zu faul und hast ihn weggeworfen im Müll. Ja, aber was für uns Müll ist, ist für so einen Bonsai-Baum vielleicht der Himmel. Man weiss es ja nicht. Wisst ihr wie ein Baum denkt? Der Baum denkt nicht. Man weiss es nicht genau, aber ich habe dem Bonsai-Baum auf jeden Fall geholfen. Und der Kaktus hat es nicht überlebt, Bonsai-Baum hat es nicht überlebt, nichts hat es überlebt.
Nichts.
Bei mir überleben nicht mal die Pflanzen, die nicht echt sind.
Ich habe noch eine Pflanze, wo ein Preisschild dran hängt.
Und nicht mal dazu bin ich in der Lage, das abzumachen.
Ich habe zwei Jahre lang eine Pflanze gegossen, die eine Plastikpflanze war.
Ja, aber man ist das seht.
Die sehen aber auch mittlerweile sehr echt aus.
Ja, die sehen extrem echt aus. Ich konnte mich bei Ikea wirklich nicht unterscheiden, was eine Pflanze ist und was nicht. Ich habe dann gemerkt, vielleicht hattest du noch nie eine echte Pflanze in der Hand. Jede Pflanze, die du in der Hand hattest, war vielleicht eine Fake-Pflanze. Jede. Lustigerweise erkenne ich es auch nur an dem Raum, in dem es drin steht. Im Gartencenter sind immer die unechten Pflanzen meistens drinnen. Ja? Ja, oder? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Das ist ein sehr spezielles, spezielles Thema. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Von Milben zu Bonsai-Bäumen, wo im Gartencenter Dinge stehen. Naja, für Milben ist ein Bonsai-Baum wiederum normaler Baum. Man könnte auch sagen, man könnte die zusammen servieren. Das ist alles eine Frage der Perspektive. Es ist wirklich alles eine Frage der Perspektive. Neulich hätte ich einen coolenpektive. Ich habe mir abends ein Video zum Einschlafen eingezogen von so einer Einstein-Dokumentation. Und dann bin ich dabei eingeschlafen, habe den Laptop zugeklappt und bin morgens bei der Arbeit, habe ich die wieder aufgeklappt. Und dann kennt man das ja noch, dass YouTube weitergeht und es fiel der Satz und das hat Einstein so nicht vorher gesehen. Der ist ja geil! Der perfekte Satz. Das braucht man als Handyklingelton. Egal was passiert, man fällt hin, das hat Einstein nicht so vorhergesehen. Oh, oh, mein YouTube-Video war noch an. Ja, man denkt sofort, es klingt sofort für Außenstehende so, als ob er sich gerade sehr, sehr für Einstein interessiert.
Ist grossartig. Vor allem, ich finde es ja so gut, dass Einstein nicht nur im grossen klug war, sondern auch im kleinen.
Und er hat ja anscheinend so eine Technik entwickelt, wie man nur kurz schläft.
So, der wollte sich kurz hinlegen, so, eh ist gleich, ach komm, ich lebe mich kurz hin.
So, und dann hat er sich hingelegt und hat den Schlüssel in der Hand und hat dann so lange geschlafen, bis er einschläft und den Schlüssel loslässt, der Schlüssel fällt auf den Boden und er wacht auf.
Ja, geil. Genial. Genial. Absolut genial.
Was hast du erfunden?
Die Milben, das Milbengericht. Und ich habe letztes erfunden, kein Witz, pass auf, und die Telegram-User wissen es schon, was ich letztens erfunden habe, ich bin im kulinarischen Modus, den Burger King Saturn. Den Burger King Saturn? Der Burger King Saturn, jetzt pass auf, Chili Cheese Nugget in einen Zwiebelring gesteckt. Danke, danke, da hat jemand, ja, danke, es kommt, es dauert ein bisschen, es dauert ein bisschen, man muss ein bisschen nachdenken. Ich war gerade, meinte er jetzt eine Saturn-Filiale in den McDonalds oder eine McDonalds in der Saturn-Filiale? Nein, ich meine den leckersten Planeten unseres Universums, den Saturn, natürlich. Geil. Ja, und vor allem, das ist genial, weil du kannst dann so seitlich reinbeissen und dann fällt alles auseinander und dann ist es ein anderer. Das ist doch perfekt. Aber du kannst auch den Rand wecknabbern. Generell, Leute, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Hauptgerichte. Ich mache jetzt alles nur noch über Beilagen. Ich mache nur noch Beilagen. Reis mit Kartoffeln. Und wirklich, das ist das Beste, gerade bei so Fastfood-Restaurants, muss man mal ganz ehrlich sein, der Burger ist eigentlich das, was man am wenigsten will. Ich sag's jetzt, ich hau mal was raus. Im Grunde will man eigentlich die geilen Beilagen.
Du willst die schönen Curly Fries, du willst die Zwiebelringe, du willst die Chili-Cheese-Nuggets, du willst die Pommes.
Der Burger King ist direkt um die Ecke, Leute. Und alles kannst du haben.
Eigentlich, du arbeitest dich durch den Burger durch, hast aber schon so die Augen auf den Pommes eigentlich.
Und deswegen sag ich, nur noch Beilagen bestellen. Nur noch Beilagen.
Zwei Arten Pommes, Curly Fries mit Fries, du steckst die eine in die andere rein. Das ist halt die Spule. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich auf diesem Weg folgen kann. Ich merke immer bei Sushi zum Beispiel, dass ich mir oft nur Beilagen bestelle. Und wenn es nicht gerade Foodora wäre, würde der Mensch, mit dem er gegenübersteht, bei der Bestellung sagen, ja und, wozu wollen Sie das Essen? Das ist kein Essen, was Sie bestellt haben. Beilagen sind das bessere Essen, hundertprozentig. Wirklich, mark my words, in 20 Jahren gibt es keine Hauptgerichte mehr. Okay, steile These. Da gibt es nur noch Beilagen. Oh, apropos, wo wir uns gerade dem Jahresende nähern, wir haben dieses Jahr eine Vorhersage, wir haben letztes Jahr eine Vorhersage getroffen, die wir genailt auch wirklich haben gesagt joko und klas werden keine grosse rolle mehr spielen als duo und was ist passiert da hat jemand eine flasche Es tut mir leid, Joko, aber es ist die Wahrheit. Auch wenn er dann nicht so hoch geworfen, so...
Das ist wirklich gruselnd.
Aber es stimmt, aber ich meine, wir kriegen nicht mal dafür einen richtigen Vorhersageapplaus, es ist einfach schwierig. Nee, es ist schwierig, in Köln ist alles gewohnt. Wir haben es geschafft. Wir haben es geschafft. Wir müssen eigentlich noch eine zweite Voraussage machen. Wir müssen jetzt eine Voraussage für 2019 machen. Joko und Klaas werden wieder eine grössere Rolle spielen. So Nostradamus, er hat jede Aussage mit Joko und Klaas zu tun, ein ganzes Buch. Und 2020 werden sie ihr erstes Album rausbringen, Mark My Words, 2020 wird der erste von den beiden sein erstes Album rausbringen. Hä? Ja? Wer sagt sie ihm, Leute? Ich meine, du bist ganz weit weg, okay, von, okay, von uns Leuten, wir sind am Puls der Zeit. Ich bin raus aus dem Leben. Klaas hat schon ein paar Alben rausgebracht, mit seiner Band Gloria. Ich glaube, aber wirklich Rentner, ich glaube im Ernst, Rentner... Hast du so gesagt, als ob man das schneidet nachher. Man hört nur den Lacher ab, nach dem, was du gesagt hast. Das ist sehr lustig, Stefan. Ich glaube, die Zukunft gehört den Rentnern und deswegen versuche ich mein Leben auch damit auf Rentner auszulegen. Es gibt immer mehr Rentner und deswegen versuche ich den ersten... Die Zukunft gehört aber nicht den jetzigen Rentnern. Das ist ein Missverständnis. Die Zukunft gehört den Rentnern, nicht die, die jetzt leben. Denen gehört gar nichts. Zwei Wochen maximum. Naja, wer mit der Zukunft geht, geht mit den Rentnern, sag ich. Die Zukunft gehört den Rentnern, deswegen brauchen wir Social Media für Rentner, wir brauchen YouTube für Rentner. Wer es schafft, wer der, sag ich mal, der Alt-Suckerberg sein will, wer es schafft, die alten Sachen, das alte Internet. Wir brauchen ein komplett neues Internet, das für alte Leute denkt. Altes YouTube, altes Internet, altes Twitter und dann damit machst du Millionen. Die haben Geld und Zeit und Spaß. Und genau das kann dir das Internet nehmen, alle drei. Das stimmt schon. Und da müssen wir ansetzen, wir müssen die alten ausbeuten. Wir müssen die alten Leute ausbeuten. Wie, was stellst du dir vor, ein YouTube-Kanal? Wie sieht ein Podcast für alte Leute aus? B26. Oh, ja, laut Bingo. I31. Hat jemand, hat jemand Bingo, dieser Podcast macht keinen Sinn. Schreibt eine Mail. Schreibt uns eine Postkarte. Wir warten jetzt 24 Stunden auf die erste Mail. Wo man noch so Postkarten abschickt mit einem Postfach. Was ist ein Postfach? Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben ein Postfach gesehen. Weißt du, worauf ich Lust habe? Ein Schiffe versenken-Podcast. Du sagst eine Zahl und ein anderer Podcast... Oh, lass uns das mit Gästliste Geisterball machen. Also, wir fangen an. B3. Ja, Moment mal, wir müssen ja erstmal die Schiffe legen. Ja, das können wir ja dann nachher Sendung machen. Aber ich sage jetzt B3. Ich sage, wir treffen schön den Frachter von den B3. Ja, aber dann können die doch jetzt ihre Schiffe so legen, dass B3 kein Schiff ist. Verstehe ich. Das ist kompliziert, wahnsinnig kompliziertes Format. Wir machen erst, wir legen erst die Schiffe. Wir sagen erst B3. Wir sagen dann und dann sagen wir, aber wir sind ja fair, sagen dann B3 als erstes. Das stimmt. Ist das eine gute Idee? Nee, ich glaube gar nicht. Gar nicht. Man muss alles als Podcast denken. Wir brauchen einen Mindsweeper-Podcast, wir brauchen einen Schiffeversenken-Podcast, alles nochmal noch als Podcast. Das finde ich gut. Kann man eigentlich gut werden im Schiffeversenken? Gibt es da Meisterschaften oder sowas? Ich glaube, statistisch gesehen kannst du gut werden. Du kannst ja in jedem Quatschspiel statistisch gut, auch Tic-Tac-Toe und so. Ich glaube, Tic-Tac-Toe zu verlieren, der muss schon richtig dusselig sein. Also richtig, richtig dämlich. Das stimmt. Weil, und ich habe auch schon viele Tic-Tac-Toe-Matches verloren. Und weil das Video angekommt, das ist How to never lose a Tic-Tac-Toe again and be a total hero at every party. Genau. Und Stefan, ja, da muss man angucken. Hero at party. Ja, wenn ich Frauen ins Spiel schlage, dann mögen wir nicht. Die Leute stehen in Schlange. Alle wollen den One-Night-Stand, der kann Tick-Tack-Toe. Das stimmt. Nee, aber ich glaube, du musst, ich glaube, statistisch gesehen ist es schon, es ist mindestens ein Unentschieden. Ich glaube, eigentlich, wenn alle aufmerksam sind, gibt es immer Unentschieden. Ja, aber das ist das Punkt. Nicht jeder ist aufmerksam. Das heißt, nur die Leute, die nicht aufmerksam sind, verlieren nicht. Also ist die beste Strategie, ablenken. In einem wahnsinnigen Ablenken. Ablenken? Das ist eine gute Idee. Grosse Nase auf. Bestimmt rassistische Parolen schreien. Genau. So ein Aufzug. Wenn du so mit mir spielen würdest, könnt ihr mich konzentrieren. Ich könnte mir nicht ein Loch in der Hose vielleicht hilft. Ja, Mitleid, einfach sagen, wenn ich verliere, dann nehmen wir mein Haus weg. Und der neue Weltmeister im Tic-Tac-Toe ist dieser Mann ohne Haus. Ich glaube, so könnten wir noch Schachweltmeister werden. Ja, das stimmt. Mit wahnsinnig viel Mitleid. Meine Frau hat gesagt, das Letzte bevor sie gestorben ist, war ihr letzter Wunsch, dass ich Weltmeister im Schach werde. Und Magnus Carlsen so, huch, leider runtergefallen, jetzt, schade, gewonnen einfach. Meine Frau ist in der Antarktis gestorben und hat mir einen Brief hinterlassen, der schon Witwer stand. Okay, schiess ins Tor, ich gehe zur Seite. Der Schachweltmeister so, ja, sie war in der Antarktis, das ist, was haben sie erwartet. Und die Fussball-WM geht schon wieder an Ecuador, wegen dem sehr traurigen Torwart. Weil die alle wie Antarktis wollen. Ich glaube, man kann viel durch Mitleid erreichen, auch so ein Musikalbum, wo du einfach sagst. Deswegen stehen wir hier und ihr sitzt da unten, weil wenn man sehr viel mit Mitleid erreichen kann. Oh, ihr seid sehr nett, Dankeschön. Aber einfach, dass du sagst, ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, hoffentlich kauft das jemand. Und dann kaufen uns allein schon ganz viele Leute aus Mitleid. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Taktik. Ich bin nicht sicher. Wie oft gibst du Obdachlosen Geld, die dir leidtun? Immer. Klar. Klar. Manchmal. Ich behaupte, ich habe selten Kleingeld, weil ich immer nur, ich habe wirklich nie Kleingeld, weil ich immer nur versuche mit Karte zu zahlen. Das ist keine gute Strategie, weil Deutschland dafür nicht ausgelegt ist und ich oft einfach nicht frühstücke morgens, weil man bei den Bäckern nicht mit Karte zahlen kann. Weil ich dieses strenge Dogma habe, immer mit Karte zu zahlen. Und ich behaupte, ich würde Obdachlosen mehr Geld geben, das ist sehr speziell, wenn die so ein Kartenlesegerät hätten. Ja, das stimmt. Oder Paypal einfach. Ja, oder Paypal. Oder Bitcoin. Oder Apple Pay. Das stimmt schon. Das sage ich ja immer. Und die sagen immer, ich verstehe nicht, was sie sagen. Ja. Haben Sie Apple Pay? Haben Sie Apple Pay? Haben Sie Apple Pay? Ob Sie Apple Pay haben? Haben Sie Apple Pay? Ich habe meine, meine, meine grösste Finanzanlage ist ja Kleingeld. Ich habe ein Kilo mit wahnsinnig viel Kleingeld zuhause. Und ich habe einfach nur Angst, dass wenn ich den eines Tages irgendwie zur Bank trage, mit diesem riesigen Eimer 40 Kilo Kleingeld. Das ist wie so Geldtransport. Du musst dann so einen Kötter-Security anrufen. Aber dass ich dann an Obdachlosen vorbeikomme. Und dann bin ich mit diesem riesen Eimer Kleingeld und so, sorry.
Das ist sehr viel Geld. Das ist so viel Geld, das können sie sich nicht vorstellen.
Leuten ausweichen und dann so, sorry, oder einfach so, na gut, einfach so, zack, dann nehmen sie es halt.
Ich weiß, das wird der schlimmste Tag. Noch lustiger finde ich es was, wenn so zwei Security-Leute hinter dir herlaufen, weil die Geldtransport mieten und so zwei schwer bewaffnete Menschen hinter dir herlaufen und die eskortieren. Und ich habe mir überlegt, dass ich der Welt etwas Gutes tue und dann so Münzen vom Hochhaus werfe, dass es allen gut geht, aber dann haben diese Mythbusters folge gesehen, dass wenn irgendwie ein Cent-Stück von mehr als hundert Meter Feldern tödlich ist. Nichts passiert. Nein, nichts passiert. Der nett gemeinteste Massenmord der Menschheitsgeschichte. Ich wollte doch nur nett sein. Zwei Millionen Menschen. Tatsächlich klappt das nicht. Nee. Weil, ähm, so. Ich versuch's mal. Oh Gott, diese eine Doku, die er mal gesehen hat, als er 17 war und jetzt nicht mehr erhielt. Du vergisst immer alles. Mensch, vergisst man, ich weiß nicht, ob es mein Digital Native Gedächtnis ist. Ich verstehe, ich kann mir Dokus angucken. Ich habe mir eine Einstein-Doku angeguckt. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht. Vor allem ist es noch merkwürdig, weil dein Gehirn interessiert sich ja dafür, sonst würdest du es sich angucken. Dein Gehirn sagt aber trotzdem, oh ne, ist gleich wieder raus. Als es sagt, gib es mir, ja, ja, ja, ja, ein Stück noch, ein Stück noch, ein Stück noch, ein Stück noch und weg. Als es in deinem Gehirn schon,irn schon dass es zum einschlafen kurs ja na ja jedenfalls glaube ich dass der luftwiderstand irgendwann genauso groß ist wie das gewicht des pfennigs aber der luftwiderstand bremst die Geschwindigkeit aus. Könnte man dieses Luft durch die Zähne haben von tausend? Ne, könnt ihr rechts und plötzlich ist der Vakuum. Ja, Leute, atmet nicht zu viel. Das klingt wie dieses Instrument, wo so ganz viele kleine Dinger in so einer Röhre drin sind. Wo man einfach so, ich spiele E-Gitarre, ich spiele Trompete, ich spiele ... Aber dann ist es, es geht nie so lang, es geht nicht lang genug auch, es ist immer sehr schnell.
Es geht nicht lang.
Ist schon vorbei.
Ah, sehr schön, ja ist gut.
Schon Hobbys.
Aber hier, Physiker, kommt das, du kriegst das nicht mehr.
Du, aber ich kenne das total, ich schaue was an und habe es wirklich noch es wirklich noch während die Moderationsstimme, der es sagt, habe ich schon wieder vergessen. Ja, da kommt Harald Lesch am Ende und sagt, naja, da haben wir ja was gelernt. Und ich scroll zurück und denke mir, ja, alles klar, dann lernen wir es jetzt nochmal. Keine Ahnung. Und es ist wirklich so, der Dreissigjährige Krieg dauerte von, und ich so, welcher Krieg? Einfach schon weg, alles weg. Ich wüsste auch nicht mehr, worum es ging, wenn Harald Lesch sagt, bis nächste Woche, wenn es nicht da stehen würde im Titel. Keine Ahnung, unschärfe Relation. Das dürfen die nicht machen, die dürfen das nicht nochmal hinschreiben. Man hat nicht mehr die Abfrage. Als Schüler hat man immer die Abfrage. Man ist so gedreht, dass man danach nochmal alles sagt. Aber so als normaler Mensch guckt man sich das an und denkt sich, ich habe den ganzen Tag verschwendet. Ich habe den ganzen Tag Dokus geguckt und ich weiß nichts mehr. Man merkt diese komische Haken. Ich glaube, bei der bei unschärfen Relation liegt ein Gag, ein sehr spezieller Gag, weil wenn man es misst, misst man ja nicht. Man misst ein falsches Ergebnis, weil man durch das Messen schon etwas beeinflusst. So und jetzt, wo liegt der Gag? Liegt doch irgendwo ein Witz, wenn man etwas misst, funktioniert das nicht mehr, weil man damit beeinflusst, wie das ist. So, das versteht ihr jetzt nicht, aber Quantenmechaniker lachen sich kaputt, das ist lustig, aber da liegt doch irgendwo ein Witz, wenn man etwas misst. Wenn ihr jetzt in Cernwärth die Stadt explodiert. Ja, ja, ja. Alle, ah, versteht ihr?
Den will ich nicht ablenken vom Arbeiten, das ist ein Zeugnis, ein Schweizeres Loch oder sowas. Das war ja wirklich einfach eine Angst, die Leute hatten. Ne, das ist ja keine Angst, die Leute hatten, das ist der klassische Wissenschaftsjournalismus, wo ich jetzt auch mal Kritik äussern muss, wo alle dann so, könnte ein schwarzes Loch entstehen, Panik, Panik und die Wissenschaftler, ne. Ne, aber nee, nee, manche Wissenschaftler. Manche panischen Journalisten rufen an, oh mein Gott, wie groß wird das sein? Nee, stimmt nicht. Gibt es da eine Hotline eigentlich, wo einfach Leute beschäftigt werden, die sagen, nob, ist anders. Ich glaube, es gibt eine Hotline, wo einfach Leute anrufen und die Antwort ist immer, nee. Nee, nee, nee, nee, das haben sie völlig falsch verstanden. Ciao, ciao. Ich wurde heute von der Hotline angerufen, von einer Telekom. Ich war auf dem Weg hierher und dann plimmelte mein Handy und das war einfach die Telekom. Ich dachte mir, komm, du hast jetzt die Zeit, während des Autofahren soll man auf jeden Fall auch telefonieren, denn ich bin Multitaskingfähig, ich mach das jetzt mal. Und hab dann, ich hab auf Lautsprecher gemacht natürlich, hab's dann gehört und dann dachte ich mir, komm, hörst einfach mal an, ich bin mit der Haltung reingegangen, mal gucken, was sie zu sagen hat, vielleicht ist es ja heute was für heute Abend, schöner auf der Bündel zu erzählen, nee, war es nicht, es war einfach nur wahnsinnig hilfreich, und das ist meine Lehre daraus. Und am Ende des Telefonats sagt sie, wissen Sie was, mir hat noch nie jemand bis zum Ende zugehört.
Dankeschön, Herr, vor allem Titzel, sie war der einzige.
Vielen Dank B3779. Tatsächlich hat sie angefangen, sie hat schlecht aufgemacht mit
ich habe ein iPad für sie, wo ich dann dachte, na gut, aber was willst du dafür haben, dass ich das iPad bekomme?
Geld vielleicht? Ichitere nicht.
Ich habe eine Holzmelone für Sie, kommen wir nachher vielleicht ins Geschäft.
Das war ihr Aufmacher, nicht so gut, fing nicht so gut an.
Da bin ich vorweg gekommen und dann schnell habe ich gesagt, danke kein iPad.
Und dann hat sie gesagt, sie bezahlen gerade zu viel.
Und dann habe ich lange darüber gesprochen und dann hat sie gesagt am Ende,
ja, aber dagegen können wir jetzt nichts tun, sie müssen erst den Vertrag auslaufen lassen.
Vielen Dank. Und dann hat sie gesagt, sie bezahlen gerade zu viel. Und dann habe ich lange darüber gesprochen und dann hat sie gesagt am Ende, ja, aber dagegen können wir jetzt nichts tun, sie müssen erst den Vertrag auslaufen lassen. Ich wünsche ihnen eine gesegnete Weihnachtszeit. Das fing wirklich sehr schnell an. Und dann hat sie mir das gewünscht und dann hat sie aufgelegt. Ich dachte mir, wow, sie wollte nicht mehr, dass ich jetzt was verlängere oder so. Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn. Ich habe heute tatsächlich auch mit einem Hotline telefoniert von den netten Menschen, die unsere Website hosten, die das machen. Und das sind wirklich die Leute, mit denen ich am wenigsten telefonieren will, weil ich habe überhaupt gar keine Ahnung. Und die so, ja, sie haben ja vor zwei Tagen ein SSL-Zertifikat aufgegeben, das ist jetzt nicht auf dem Server angekommen, da haben sie leider das Lezeichen und ich so, ja, ja, ja, ja, ich weiss schon, ja, wie dumm kann man sein, SSLQ irgendwie nur mit zwei Lehrzeichen, okay, mache ich, mache ich, alles klar, ciao und mache ich nie, einfach, das ist wirklich so, wenn du mit einem Latein-LK-Lehrer lernst und du hast kein einziges Wort und er ist einfach so, ja, sie müssen, ja, sie haben ja, ihr steht schon vor zwei Monaten, habe ich ihnen ja schon gesagt, dass sie die Aufträge zusammenlegen müssen. Ja, und das ist ja immer noch nicht passiert, und deswegen müssen wir leider, steht immer das Zertifikat immer noch aus. Ja, und da müssen Sie sich darum kümmern. Ja, okay, tschüss. Schrecklich. Nee, man kann es nicht machen. Ach, ich war heute auch in der Werkstatt. Heute war ein bisschen Tag. Der erlebnisreichste Tag aller Zeit. Tatsächlich, Gott sei Dank. Ich bin heute schon beflogen. Das ist auch lustig, das Flugbegleiter. Jeden Tag fliegen. Ja, aber und dann waren die mal in Ägypten und dann fliegen die zurück und der halbe Tag ist rum. Wie weird das ist, wie seltsam das ist, ich war halt in Ägypten. Okay. Und dann fragt dich jemand, kannst du morgen und du sagst, ja, ich bin in Ägypten. Und dann sagen, ja okay, ja, aber abends um 18 Uhr habe ich Zeit. Das heißt, wir werden das mitbringen. So eine kleine, unerthinige Brau. Ich kann davor auch gerne aus Einkaufen gehen, danach gehe ich in das Fitnessstudio, aber dann komme ich auch um 18 Uhr, okay? Ja. Schon seltsam. Und das ist auch so, man hat immer Angst vor den Leuten, bei einer Autowerkstatt, die erwarten so ein bisschen so ein Grundwissen über das Auto und das habe ich ja nicht. Und dann zum Beispiel heute morgen dachte ich mir, verdammt mein Auto ist so dreckig, ich will es in die Werkstatt bringen, was mache ich schnell? Einzige Idee, die ich hatte war, den ganzen Kram schnell in den Kofferraum zu stopfen, in der Hoffnung, dass die da ja nicht ran müssen. Warum muss man in den Kofferraum? Warum sollte man in den Kofferraum?
Da bin ich mit meinem Auto hingefahren und da hat er gesagt, heute ist der TÜV fällig,
okay, alles klar, können wir uns das Auto mal angucken.
Ich habe schon gesagt, bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte nicht in den Kofferraum kommen.
Und dann mal seine erste Frage war, haben Sie einen Verbandsgast im Kofferraum?
Und ich habe gesagt, ja.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist recht hoch tatsächlich, wenn sie so war.
Irgendwas, da sind mehrere Verbandsgästen wahrscheinlich drin.
Und das erste, was ich mache, muss ich den Kofferraum aufmachen.
Und man sieht schon an dem, der hasst das so. Die Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl der Zahl Was ich tatsächlich immer gemacht habe, und zwar ich bin ein Freund der Impulsivware im Supermarkt, ich kaufe mir so eine Kinderriegel-Dublo, aber das Problem an denen, dass sie immer recht warm und weich sind. Also was mache ich? Clever, Wagen voll, ich gehe bald zur Kasse, ich hole mir den Dublo und lege ihn noch schön ins Gefrierfach, schön zwischen die tiefgefrorenen Pommes, ja, zwischen die tiefgefrorenen Pommes dazu, dann lege ich alles auf die Kasse, hab dann noch genug Zeit, um wieder zum Gefrierfach zu gehen, schön zwischen den Pommes, ja, zwischen tiefgefrorenen Pommes dazu, dann lege ich alles auf die Kasse, hab dann noch genug Zeit, um wieder zum Gefrierfach zu gehen, schön zwischen den Pommes rauszuholen und einen knackig kalten Kinderriegel. Wie oft hast du es vergessen, sei ehrlich. Ja, ich habe es tatsächlich ein paar Mal vergessen. Wie viel ist es wie so ein Eichhörnchen, was ich überlege, ich lege mir das zurück und dann sagt die Eiche, ha ha ha, neuer Baum. Und irgendwann, ich glaube, irgendwann, wenn Edeka irgendwann mal diese Gefrierschränke rausräumt, einfach unten eine Schicht. Aber tatsächlich habe ich einmal einen Kinderriegel drunter gelegt, gehen Schritt zur Seite, guckt nach rechts und da kommt tatsächlich ein Mitarbeiter mit einer riesigen Packung Pommes, Tiefkühlpommes. Die wurden gerade befüllt. Und ich stand wie angefroren daneben, weil ich mir einfach dachte, das ist mein kleines Geheimnis. Das ist zwischen mir und dem Kinderriegel, das darf niemand wissen. Und dann tatsächlich, wirklich wie in einem Film, und ich garantiere euch zu 100 Prozent, dass es war, die Frau geht auch genau wie bei dir zu dem Ding, macht auf und sortiert erst mal die um, nimmt die erste Packung Pommes runter, sieht direkt meinen Kinderriegel und sagt auch, Günther, wir haben drei Achter. Drei Achter-Elarm. Da kommt das Milchglas und der Kinderriegel. Ja genau, das ist ein Fall für die Milch! Und die nimmt diesen Kinderregel und guckt auch wirklich wie durch eine göttliche Eingebung einfach direkt mich an. Und jetzt ist die Frage. Dein Kindershirt hat ich mir echt verraten. Und die Schokolade um meinen Mund rufen. Aber jetzt ist die Frage. Folgendes. Ich gebe jetzt mal das Quiz an die Zuschauer, welchen Ausdruck hatte sie auf ihrem Gesicht? Ja, fang doch unsere Zuschauer, dann fang die an uns zu beleidigen. Es ist nicht so leicht, weil wie reagiert man darauf? Du findest in deiner Arbeit irgendwo einen tiefgefrorenen Kinderregel steinhart in deiner Hand und holst ihn raus, guckt mich an. Und ich gebe euch jetzt mal drei
Gesten und dann könnt ihr mal gucken, wie sie reagiert. Achtung, Geste eins. Das war deine Geste?
Nee, welche Geste sie gemacht hat. Okay, ja, ich darf mich deine Geste raten. Ja, Geste zwei, ja, oder Geste drei, okay, okay. Was sagt ihr Geste eins, zwei oder drei? Ob ihr wirklich richtig dreht, seht ihr, wenn das Licht angeht. Wie ist es, eine Kind, das bei eins, zwei oder drei auf der falschen Zeit steht, sie denkt, du Depp, als ob alle anderen falsch liegen, du Vollidiot. Das ist bescheuert. Das ist wie wenn du bei Google was eingebst, sie hieß es schon, ob du auf dem richtigen Weg bist. Andere Leute haben es auch gesucht. Wenn es noch jemanden gesucht hat, bist du vielleicht auf dem falschen Weg. Und die richtige Antwort ist zwei. Antwort Nummer zwei. Was macht zwei nochmal? Sie hat reagiert mit einem, komm schon, was soll das? Ja, einem, als würde sie das jeden Tag finden, als würde sie wirklich jeden, als wäre es ein besseres Ort auch, als kommst du im Tiefregal?
So, als wenn ein 15-Jähriger versucht, Wodka zu kaufen mit so einer tiefen Stimme.
Guten Tag, edles Fräulein! Und sie so, kam schon.
Und genau so war die Reaktion auf den gefundenen Kinderriegel. Aber es könnte alles sein!
Und ich dachte mir so, wie ist das jetzt? Und ich habe mich angegriffen Kinderriegel. Aber das könnte alles sein.
Und ich dachte mir so, wie das jetzt... Und ich habe mich angegriffen gefühlt, weil das war mein kleines Geheimnis.
Das wussten wir sie und ich.
Und ich dann nur so, ja damit er ein bisschen kalt ist.
Und sie wirklich kein Verständnis.
Och Gott, und dann gehst du Nummer drei.
Und ich war noch nie so gedemütigt in meinem Leben.
Und danach stand so Bier angewürzt vom Brokkoli. Und dann, bitte lass dich nicht da reingucken. Bitte niemals, hoffentlich sollst du niemals von einem Brokkoli nach. Oh Gott, nicht zum Schlemmerfilet, nicht zum Schlemmerfilet, fuck. Aber warum offenbarst du dich? Warum machst du nicht ein... Ja, weil ich an einem einen Riegel musste. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, keine Ahnung wer das war und dann sieben Minuten später so, dann war das rausgehend nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, die hatte wahnsinnig viel Pommes. So eine Ahnung, wie viel Pommes jeden Tag gekauft werden in Deutschland. Ich mag Pommes sehr, das ist meine Top-1-Beilage. Aber interessant. Aber es kann auch alles bedeuten. Diese Geste kann auch bedeuten, nur eins. Wenn du das schon machst, dann nimm doch wenigstens drei.
Der ganze Aufwand, Kinderregel immer nur die Kleinen in der Zehnerpackung, hallo? Es ist einfach schwer zu lesen. Ich hätte mir jemanden genommen, der sich nicht wehren kann, hätte den beschuldigt. So ein Rollstuhlfahrer oder unerweilig, weil die können sich nicht wehren, wenn die geschoben werden, was soll passieren? Die drehen sich nicht um und gucken, wer sie, also, oder alte Menschen einfach anschieben und sagen, aha.
Vor allem, es war so eine Situation. Was soll passieren? Die drehen sich nicht um und gucken, wer sich... Oder alte Menschen einfach anschieben und sagen, ach...
Vor allem, es war so eine Situation...
Man legt manchmal Dinge weg.
Schon wieder der Kinderriegel, na, Ursula, ah, Mensch.
Auch so Pfleger von Leuten, die immer einen dabei haben, das ist auch ideal.
Einmal so, oh Mensch, blöd.
Aber tatsächlich war das...
Ich meine, ich weiß, dass Zivilcourage nicht allzu gross geschrieben wird in diesem Land, ist uns allen klar. Aber das war ein Moment, wo ich mir dachte, da hätten mir Leute helfen sollen. Da hätten Leute zu, ja stimmt, die sind wirklich immer ein bisschen warm, wirklich, und dann so eine ganze Revolution, die dann irgendwie die ganzen Edeka umwirft und dann so, fuck it. Warum ist nicht direkt alles gekühlt? Ja, die sollen gekühlt sein, so wie die Vanilla Coke, die Kleine. Die gibt es gar nicht warm zu kaufen. Aber wirklich, da habe ich Leute, niemand hat mir geholfen. Ich habe gesagt, damit die ein bisschen kalt sind. Niemand hat mir geholfen. Niemand hat geholfen. Einer hat gerufen, na, er sass uns in Ruhe. Er sass uns in den Decken in Ruhe. Keiner war auf meiner Seite. Das ist wirklich eine Wegguck-Gesellschaft. Das ist eine Wegguck-Gesellschaft, vor allem bei den Themen. Es ist eine Kinderringelversteck Versteck und dann Weckuckgesellschaft. Wie man Schokolade und jetzt kommt mir nicht mit, oh es ist Winter, es ist eh kalt. Nee, selbst im Winter sind die zu warm. Es ist einfach so, die müssen selbst dann auch eisgekühlt werden. Aber isst du denn auch in Kinderringel tiefgekühlt? Also machst du denn, nee, ich meine jetzt zu Hause, machst du das Tiefkühlfach? Das Problem ist, und jetzt überleg mich. Mein Vorschlag für alle, die ein bisschen Geld in der Tasche haben. Jeder, der 100 Euro in der Tasche hat, eben mal die Hand. Die sind alle steinreich, die haben 26 Euro dafür. Aber es hat niemand 100 Euro dabei gerade. Ernsthaft, ihr schämt euch dafür, dass ihr mehr als 100 Euro dabei habt? Die Getränke sind teuer. Leute, unsere Tickets müssen teurer werden. Wir leben hiervon. Die Getränke sind teuer. Leute, unsere Tickets müssen teurer werden. Wir leben hier vorne. Die Getränke sind da gut. Und zwar Idee. Unsere Gesellschaft besteht aus zwei Räumen, dem Kühlschrank und dem Gefrierfach. Das reicht mir nicht. Unser Leben besteht aus zwei Gebäudenräumen. Es gibt den Kühlschrank und es gibt den Gefrierfach. Und ich sag Freunde, wir brauchen was dazwischen. Ich sag's hier und jetzt, wir brauchen was dazwischen. Niemand ist auf meiner Seite! Niemand! Forstapplaus. Aber ganz kurz, gibt es da nicht was dazwischen? Nein, ich glaube, das ist wirklich mein Problem mit Schokobriegel. Ist Kühlschrank kälter stellen nicht dazwischen? Kühlschrank ist zu kalt, Gefrierfach ist Kühlschrank. Komm noch mal rein. Vielleicht sollte ich keine Firma leiten. Gut, ich habe den Punkt verstanden. Dankeschön. Gefrierfach ist zu kalt, Kühlschrank ist zu warm. Wir brauchen was dazwischen. Wir brauchen das... Was? Fahr euch fort. Ich wollte mir da was zu trinken. Ich wollte nur dahingehend mir was Wasser holen. Wir brauchen das Kühlregal. Es ist zwischen dem Kühlschrank und dem Gefrierfach. Niemand ist auf meiner Seite. Niemand ist auf deiner Seite. Ich stelle einen grossen Eimer Kleingeld auf, da könnt ihr euer Kleingeld reinwerfen für die Idee. Und dann bringe ich den Ersten, der so ein Mittelding hat und plötzlich sagt alle, verdammt, der hat recht, verdammt, die hat immer gefehlt. Dies ist ein Zwischending. Immer noch nicht.
Fakir.
In eurem Wasser. Es ist ein gutes Wasser.
Ja, Prost.
Es ist vor allem kein deutsches Wasser, Fonte da Fraga, Fonte da Fraga, spanisches Wasser.
Ajoa de Manatial. Spanisches Wasser? Ich krieg's nicht auf.
Komm, ich mach's auf.
Danke.
Das muss ich auch reinkommen.
Danke, Stefan.
Ja, das sind meine Muskeln.
Das sind meine Armmuskeln, die ich mit der Beinpresse trainiert habe, weil ich keine Arme habe.
Manche Muskeln...
Irgendwann habe ich so grosse Oberschenkel, grosse Arme, einfach weil ich Falschträder und so Hände an den Füssen. Da kann auch echt viel schief. Das ist auch nicht gut, wenn man nicht weiß, wo man dran trainiert, glaube ich. Weil du trainierst so, hast drei Arme und zwei Beine, so kann ich dir helfen. Nein, ich weiss, wie das funktioniert. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was hier passiert. Und dann vor allem diese Mitgliedschaft ist auch nicht so all in. Dann gibt es da zum Beispiel so einen Wasserspender. Da bin ich mit meiner Trinkfleisch da hingegangen und dann habe ich meinen Band drangehalten und dann steht da Zugriff verweigert. Zugriff verweigert für Wasser in einem Fitnessstudio. Ja, gut. Das waren ergiebige 20 Minuten Training auf jeden Fall, kann ich sagen. Wovon ich 19 Minuten Candy Crush gespielt habe. Wovon ich 19 Minuten geguckt habe, was für Geräte da sind, die ich kenne. Tatsächlich, ich finde ja immer erstaunlich, es gibt ja Fernsehsender, die jeder sehen kann. Und dann gibt es noch so diese merkwürdige Parallelwelt von Fernsehsendern, die nur in bestimmten Orten laufen. Wie halt zum Beispiel, es gab mal einen Burger King Fernsehsender, sorry, dass ich heute oft bei Burger King bin, Burger King, ich hab Hunger, einfach, der Fernsehsender nur bei Burger King läuft oder auch Fernsehsender, die nur in Fitnessstudios laufen. Und ich habe Fitnessstudio und da habe ich zum Beispiel gesehene Sportart, professionelles Fangen. Man fängt sich gegenseitig, was man als Kinder so macht, machen die professionell, die fangen sich gegenseitig. Wo ich mir wie ich dachte, du sitzt da und sollst pumst da und sollst motiviert werden von dem Gedanken, so gut würde ich auch mal gerne fangen können. Also der kann schon wirklich verdammt gut fangen. Gab es Zuschauer? Statten Leute am Rand, die gejubelt haben? Ja, es gab auch Vogelfrei in der Mitte. Nee, das ist ja alles wie so ein Hindernisparcours, nur dass man sich halt gegenseitig da durchjagt, weil man vielleicht zu viel Zeit hat. Keine Ahnung, ich weiss es nicht genau. Aber das haben die sich ausgewählt, die müssen überlegen, was motiviert die Leute am meisten dazu, ihre Muskeln zu stellen, Fangstie. Das war deren Angriff. Vor allem, es gibt ja Quidditch, echt. Es gibt Leute, die wirklich Quidditch spielen und man muss den Schnatz fangen. Und die laufen durch die Gegend an Wesen zwischen den Ball. Und der Schnatz ist einfach ein Mensch im Ballkostüm. Es ist wirklich so. Und den muss man dann fangen. Und das spielen Leute gegeneinander. Aber ganz im Ernst, klar, cool, ihr seid Fans und so, hey, ich bin geil im Libyoso, Libyosa, wir kennen das alle aus, aber das funktioniert doch nicht wirklich, das Spiel ist doch Quatsch. Wenn jemand den Schnatz fängt, ist das Spiel vorbei, ja dann, was ist das für ein Spiel? Das hat noch keinen Sinn, da müssen alle den Schnatz fangen. Aber denk doch mal dran, du hast als Autor heutzutage eine enorme Verantwortung. Stell dir mal vor, du machst ein neues Fantasy-Universum und du weißt ganz genau, in der heutigen Nerdkultur, wo das alles so weit verbreitet ist, wird alles eins zu eins umgesetzt werden. Rowling hat geschrieben, ja, was trinken die, keine Ahnung, Butterbier, keine Ahnung. Und dann irgendwie zwanzig Jahre später, und hier ist hier Butterbier für drei Euro fünfzig.
Ja, hallo schick. Ich wollte nie, dass es so endet. Und ich hab's getrunken und es war wirklich okay. Ja? Ja.
Und ich meine auch mit anderen Erwartungshaltung ist nicht, es wird es geil schmecken.
Ich meine, genau so wird sein Butter und Bier für Sonnabell rauskommen.
Und genau so ist es mit Kuditsch auch. Die schreibt das einfach rein, die werfen den Ding da in die Röhre und Harry ist halt der Schlingo und der muss den Lango holt er den. Schlango fängt Schlim und Schlager an. Und wenn ihr 40 Frickel reingefrappt habt, dann ist das Spiel zu Ende und sind 20 Jahre später und der diesjährige Quidditch-Weltmeister Honduras schon wieder. Aber der Sieger der Frickels, der Sieger der Herzen, Frickel-Champion. Aber das machen Leute nach und das funktioniert nicht wirklich. Oder das ist doch keine Sportart. Ich verstehe. Du hast die Möglichkeit, wenn du heute einen Fantasy-Roman schreibst, du kannst nicht nur einen Fantasy-Roman schreiben, du kannst auch eine neue Sportart entwickeln. Gar einfach nebenbei, die wenn die sich durchsetzt irgendwann Olympische. Ja, Herr Will, noch mal zu dem Buch, was Sie geschrieben haben. Die Geschichte ist ein bisschen kurz gekommen, weil Sie ab Seite 12 so eine Sportart beschreiben. Ja, die Figuren wachsen halt daran. Also ich meine, Bonn und Bermine sind halt in so einer On-and-Off-Beziehung und Bonn versucht halt... Aber ganz kurz, von Seite 12 bis 87 ist eine Anleitung, einfach wie man das Spiel spielen kann. Genau, die können Sie aber rausnehmen. Das hat sich nur nicht so viel zu tun. Ja, die können Sie aber rausnehmen. Wie gesagt, das ist so imprägniert, das können Sie einfach aus dem Buch rausreisen. Wen ist der Sport nicht so interessiert. Bei dem Buch liegt ein Ball dabei. Ja, ein Lesezeichen Ball ist jetzt Ihre Auslegung. Es gibt ja auch irgendwie schon moderne Sachen, aber wie gesagt, Bonn wächst ja auch dadurch, dass er sich freiwillig zum Frippel meldet und dadurch ist es ihm wichtig für die Charaktere, dachte ich. Wenn man dann den Batz fängt, dann ist das Spiel vorbei, ist das korrekt? Genau, dann ist das Spiel vorbei, wenn bis dahin zwölf Hot Dogs verkauft wurden. Okay. Ich würde sagen, wir machen das. Okay, wunderbar, cool. Film? Ja, dreizehn Stück. Gut, danke schön. Lustigerweise, ich war gestern in dem neuen Harry Potter Film. Holy, holy shit. Warum? Ich habe nichts verstanden. Und ich, wir haben eine Folge über Harry Potter gemacht, ihr wisst, wie gut wir uns auskennen. Ja, okay. Wir haben Ahnung, wir kennen Fluffy, wir kennen, okay. Und tatsächlich habe ich nichts verstanden, ich saß noch nie in so einem Film, der eine grosse Produktion ist und ich saß wirklich on the edge of my seat, nicht weil ich es spannend fand, sondern weil ich hinhören wollte. Ich habe es nicht gecheckt. So dieses die Augen zusammengekniffen, das Ohr, was? Ich denke, entweder werden Filmmacher zu klug oder ich zu dumm. Ja, ich zu dumm glaube ich. Aber ich. Jede zweite Serie, die ich schaue, verstehe gar nichts. Es ist wirklich so, ich verstehe nichts. Handmaid's Tale, kein Plan, überhaupt nicht verstanden, was ist da los. Wirklich, House of Cards, letzte Staffel, kein einziges Wort verstanden durch die gesamte Serie. Und man denkt sich immer so, ah krass, die bauen jetzt so Mysterien auf, ah cool, okay, wer ist wohl diese Figur? Vielleicht schaust du es nicht in der richtigen Sprache. Ach, wer weiss. Du denkst dir so, ah okay, krass, welche Motivation hat er das zu tun? Und am Ende der Staffel, nee, okay, ich habe nichts verstanden. Das waren keine Mysterien, ich habe es einfach noch nicht gerafft. Aber das, was ich am seltsamsten fand, war, dass Dumbledore einfach einen normalen Anzug trägt. Das stimmt. Der trägt einen ganz normalen Anzug, wie das damals in den 20er Jahren so getragen wurde, aber so einen normalen Dreiteiler. Schön mit einem Anzug trägt. Das stimmt. Der trägt einen ganz normalen Anzug, wie das damals in den 20er Jahren halt so getragen wurde, aber so einen normalen Dreiteiler. Schön mit einer Anzughose, einem Sakko, mit einer Weste. Das war der Punkt, wo du aufgesprungen bist und die Leinwand angeschrien hast. Das ist doch, als ob man so einen Spin-off macht und Gandalf trägt Jeans. Das ist doch das Gleiche. Und dann plötzlich entscheidet er sich, nee, diese typischen Klischischee-Magierhüte mit so Sternen drauf. Sowas hätte ich gern. Sowas hätte ich gern und so einen grossen Mantel. So einen Riesenmantel in Burgunder. Aber jetzt mal unter uns, auch Voldemort trägt doch nicht immer diese dunkle Hobe. Der hat doch auch mal einen freien Tag und dann schön in so einer Jogginghhose und so ein Vigni-the-Pool-Pullover. Das ist was Voldemort trägt, wenn er keinen Bock hat, sich den Arm anzuziehen. Schön einfach so ein grosses Schlapper-Shirt. Einfach so schlappen, eine lockere Chino, irgendwie so ist er und der Fing. Schlappen, schön Schläppchen an. Und dann auch jetzt die Totesser sind alle da, okay, ich ziehe mich rum. War das wirklich der beste Name für meine Gefolgschaft, Todesser? Da müssen wir aber auch mal über J.K. Rowling sprechen. Ja, die ist komplett bescheuert. Sorry, also nichts. Aber für die sind so die, wir sind wohl bei Antenna-Ausker-Bahn, Vogel zwei, aber ganz kurz, warum, also die Muggel ist noch ein kreativer Name, aber dann hört's auf. Aber du hast auch nicht so viele Ideen, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Die Nicht-Magier. Ja, Todesser, ey, das fand ich als Kind schon immer langweilig. Todesser, essen die den Tod, sind die tot und essen die? Und dann gibt's die, bis sie tot sind. Dann gibt's die Mentoren, die wirklich den Tod essen und dann war ich völlig raus. Ja, das stimmt. Die ernähren sich vom Tod und die essen sich gegenseitig auch.
Aber die essen es Dementoren.
Ich war auch verwirrt wegen Dementor und Dumbledore, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Muss ich wirklich hundertpro... muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben.
In Teil drei saß ich Kopfkratzen da und dachte mir, der war doch gut, dachte ich.
Da habe ich keinen Wort verstanden.
Warum? Hä? Ver verstehe gar nichts. Aber Filme machen auch Spaß, wenn man nichts versteht tatsächlich. Das ist ja die Magie von Cinema, dass du im Kino sitzt und dir einfach denkst, what, yeah, was? Boah, sie fliegen auf Besen! Geil! Ja darum geht's doch auch. Die Story ist doch scheiss egal, wer da wen, in welchem Zauberstab, sie fliegen auf Besen! Das stimmt schon, ja. Lächerlich. Oder diese Astralen, diese Dinger, die man nicht sieht, wenn man den Tod noch nicht gesehen hat, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Das ist kein Mensch. Ach ja. Das ist kein Mensch. Hättest du Lust, so ein Fantasy-Universum zu schreiben, so ein Kinderbuch für ...
Ja. So wirklich mal so, oh, und jetzt aber geht's los, erste Seite, erster Satz, okay, erster Satz, die Zauberer sind, so Wort für Wort, einfach durchs gesamte Buchsteuern.
Geflohen. Die, die Zauberer sind geflohen, wir waren schon. Achso, jeder einen Satz. Achso, komm, okay, okay, wie das Buch in Schild gerade ist, ja, ja, ja, also die Zauberer sind geflohen, aber vor was? Leute, die die zu spät im Kalender gecheckt haben, dass sie morgen den Pitch haben, machen das morgen spontan. Die Zauberer sind geflohen, aber vor was? Das ist ein Satz, eine Frage, wow, du gehst regnend heute Spannung, Leute, wenn wir in den ersten 20 Sätzen die Leute nicht am Haken hast. So, ich fange an, das Universum mal ein bisschen auszumalen. Das ist dein Satz. Vor den Flammen von Astralia. Richtig gehört, Astralia. Was ist das für ein Buch?
Was ist das für ein Buch?
Richtig gehört?
Sie haben richtig gehört.
Naja, du musst sowas auch noch, du kannst sowas mehrfach betonen, fremde Begriffe.
Sie haben richtig gehört. Ich habe es gelesen.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Mir fällt, du denkst so ein bisschen das Hörbuch mit. Ja klar, natürlich. Ja, das habe ich richtig gehört. Sieh da. Die Flammen von Astalia, aus Rufezeichen. Aus Rufezeichen? Yeah. Okay. Ein bisschen wütend schon. Wütend, ja, die Flammen von Astalia. Dachte Boris. Boris war ein einfacher Mann. Man könnte fast sagen, ein Kind. Kinderbuch und so. Ein Satz nur. Er wachte auf und streckte sich. Und jetzt ist es eine normale Geschichte, so eine uncool normale Comic-Romance. Er hatte vergessen, dass heute seine Schwester Diana Geburtstag hatte. Was sollte er Diana schenken? Etwa etwas Selbstgebasteltes? Aber zurück zu den Magiern, die fliehen vor Flammen. Spannend, wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie es weitergeht, schaut den Film an, verdammt nochmal. Abstand. Ich glaube, das geht. Würdet ihr es kaufen? Ja, geht doch! Die Flammen von Australia. Wer von euch ist in unserer Telegram-Gruppe? Ganz kurz mal aufzeigen. Oh, wow! Wir haben so'n Spaß bei Telegram, wir haben richtig viel Spaß. Wahnsinn! Wir müssen aber auch die Leute mal... Sorry, dass ich jetzt mal auf dem Handy bin. Wie lustig ist, wenn ich einfach keinen Grund hätte. Aber einfach, das ist meine Person, ich kann einfach nicht ohne. Warte mal. Alter, okay, das ist crazy, jemand postet ein Bild von mir, wie ich die Gruppe vorlese, das wird mir zum Meta.
Ich scroll hoch, das ist einfach nur gruselig.
Leute, legt eure Handys weg, ihr seid bei einer Abendveranstaltung.
Hast du ein Loch in der Hose?
Nein, nein, nein, das habe ich direkt geschaut.
Wahnsinn, die Hälfte der Leute ist an ihrem Handy einfach hier nebenbei.
Könnt ihr ein Bild von mir machen, wie ich das Bild hochhalte, wie ich auf der Bühne ein Handy habe? Ganz kurz?
Okay, aber jetzt Handy weg, ohne Spaß.
Sehr gut, vor allem jetzt wissen wir, wer er ist, jetzt wissen wir, was sein Nickname ist.
Naja gut, aber wissen, dass du die ganzen Hakenkreuz-Fotos gepostet hast die ganze Zeit.
Ist ja auch schon mal was. Du bist also Udo XXX, Herzchen,herzchen, xr10x, weil alles andere schon besetzt war. Was ist das nicht? Ja, ne. Vielleicht willst du es exakt selbe sagen wie ich. Ne, ich würde sagen, mir ist noch nicht aufgefallen, du wärst am liebsten verwitwet. Ich glaube, dass der beste Zustand ist, auf LSD hängenbleiben. auf Pilzen hängenbleiben. Weil mir hat jemand erzählt, mir hat eine Freundin erzählt, dass ein guter Kumpel von ihr jetzt hängen geblieben ist auf Pilzen und deswegen glaubt, es war sehr traurig das Gespräch eigentlich, aber ich dachte mir danach, geil, weil sie erzählt und der glaubt jetzt, dass ein Drache unterm Kölner Dom lebt. Okay. Der ist wirklich der festen Überzeugung. Wir lachen alle, das ist ein ernsthafter pathologischer Zustand. Können wir mit dem ein Buch schreiben? Der Typ, der es glaubt, oder der Typ... Nee, der es glaubt, ja klar. Du willst es ja die Rechte kaufen. Ja, stimmt. Ja, oder... Aber wie kommt der da drauf? Hat ihm das jemand erzählt aus Scheiss? Nee, das hat er einfach so festgestellt. Und wie kommt er darauf, hat ihm das jemand erzählt aus Scheiss?
Nee, das hat er einfach so festgestellt. Und jetzt kommt's, das Geile daran ist, wie cool ist die Welt, in der du lebst, wenn du ernsthaft glaubst, dass ein Drache unterm kleiner Dom ist. Wie genial das ist. Und dann dachte ich mir, dann läuft man ja manchmal da lang und da ist ja auch die Philharmonie und die wird manchmal abgesperrt und so, weil darunter dann Aufführungen sind und man nicht drüber laufen soll und es Geräusche macht. Wie cool das ist alles, das ist eigentlich ein lamer Fact, aber stell dir mal vor, du denkst, da ist ein Drache drunter und dann sperren die oben diesen scheiß Platz ab und du denkst, what, was macht er? Aber die Frage ist halt, was für eine Art von Drache ist. Warum machen die das jetzt? Ist es halt eher so ein Tabaluga-netter Drache oder so ein Smaug-Drache?
Oder ist es so ein Ich bring dir Rechnen bei, Matt? Er bewacht den Schatz. Er bewacht den Schatz. Welchen Schatz? Ein Tabaluga, so ein Typ im Kostüm. Der ist ja gefangen seit mehreren hundert Jahren. Aber stell dir vor, du bleibst hängen auf LSD und hast eine langweilige Fantasie. Hey, sorry. Eigentlich ist es normal, aber du glaubst fest daran, dass ein Typ im Tabaluga-Kostüm unten im Kölner Domfestival ist. Ja, zu Unrecht in den Kerker geworfen wurde. Ey, tatsächlich, es gab aber diese Sendung... Aber der ist ja schon tot. Ich wollte schon als Kind ins Fernsehen und ich wollte in diese ganzen Sendungen. Und dann wollte ich mal nicht alleine, da hat meine Freundin gefragt, ey, komm, lass uns ins Fernsehen, lass uns be bewerben bei so einer Show und die haben gesagt so, die einzige Show, in die wir gehen würden, wäre Tabaluga und ich muss gestehen, ich hatte so viel Angst vor dem Schneemann, ich habe mich nicht getraut, da teilzunehmen, wegen des Schneemanns, weil ich mir einfach dachte, ey den Close-up, das kriegen wir. Ja, ich wirklich, ich dachte mir, fuck, lass uns doch zum Quiz-U-Boot gehen oder irgendwie sowas. Mit Commander da sitzt! Ja, ja, und vor allem das Krasse, bei dem Quiz-U-Boot vor dem Land. Das habe ich nachgebaut früher, weil wie geil das war, dass sie so Aquarien hatten und so. Da habe ich wirklich mit Leuten, auch mit meinen Eltern habe ich dann das Quiz-U-Boot nachgebaut und wollte halt auch diese Kulisse bauen und habe einfach Wassergläser auf den Tisch gestellt. Ja, weil ich diese Kulisse so toll fand. Aber bei der Bewerbung zum Quiz-U-Boot musste man seine Grösse angeben. Ja, ich habe mich auch beworben, auf jeden Fall. Tiger-Club auch. Die stellen die Stühle so ein, dass alle Kinder gleich groß sind. Ich liebe diesen Ort. Großartig! Das ist der einzige Ort, wo du... Das ist das einzige Awkward-Kind, was gar nicht mehr im Bild ist. Aber es wäre der einzige Ort, wo du nicht zu groß wärst. Ich möchte lösen B. B, 30 Jahre, der Krieg gedauert. Wieder aus dem Frame. Ihr habt gewonnen, zwei Controller für eine Playstation. Wow, das ist für die krasseste Frage. Man konnte nie coole Sachen da gewinnen. Nee, das war dafür bei der Super-Toll-Klopfer da, wo du alles gewinnen konntest. Das stimmt. Ich hasse diese Leute, habe ich mich schon mal drüber aufgeregt. Letzte Folge erst, ich mache noch mal, die Fahrräder nehmen. Leute, lass es los, Stefan. Der ganze Wagen ist voll. Lass es los. Die Sendung gibt es seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr. Lass es los. Wo ist Commander David jetzt? Der lebt jetzt unterm Kölner Dom, der ist ganz weit weg. Commander David, was macht der wohl jetzt? Das ist so eine Existenzvielfische. Vielleicht ist er DJ, vielleicht ist er DJ Snake, man weiss es nicht genau. Wissen wir, wer DJ Snake ist? Nein. Ich habe mir letztens überlegt, wie unglaublich. Ich weiss nicht mehr, wer das ist, also wer ohne den Namen, wer DJ Snake ist. Hip-Hop ist ja unfassbar, weil Hip-Hop ja wahnsinnig viele Dinge cool gemacht hat, die nicht cool sind. Rappen ist ja Gedichtaufsagen. Und Gedichtaufsagen ist mega lame, aber Rappen ist super cool. Bessere Reime finden ist Rapper. Dann gab es ja diesen Rapperkrieg auch hier in Köln, wo Leute sich beschossen haben. Und man sagt, Leute, es geht um Reime. Es geht um Reime. Orange Melange. Ihr müsst euch nicht beschissen.
Dafür muss eine Kölner Tupac sterben. Schade. Aber vor allem, ja, Sprechgesagen im Sinne von Gedichte, aber auch, was mir letztens aufgefallen hat, die haben auch cool gemacht Kieferorthopädie. Gangster mit ihren Goldzählen und so haben Kieferorthopädie cool gemacht.
Vor allem, ich dachte mir, wenn du jetzt irgendwie DJ Snake bist und du willst so die Brillis auf dem Zahn,
geht man dann einfach zum Kieferorthopäden und sitzt dann auf so einem grossen Zahn, einfach so mit lauter Kindern.
So, Herr Snake!
Ah ja, das bin ich. Guten Tag, hallo. Das bin ich. Genau.
Ja, ich dachte mir vielleicht, so über die vorderen Sexszene so,ne so Bitch in Gold, muss nicht, oder in Diamanten. Das sind dann schon normale Brackets, wie wir das von Zahnspangen kennen. Genau, ich habe als Kind auch eine Zahnspange getragen, vielleicht könnte man die wiederverwenden und dann vielleicht oben Bitch und unten vielleicht so Death. Bitch Death? Oder ... ja, jetzt muss ich es sagen, ist schon... Aber müsste ich das dann auch putzen oder würde das selber... Das müsste ich ganz normal putzen auch, ja. Wissen die Zahnseide? Ich empfehle die Zahnseide auf jeden Fall. Und Mundspülungen, gerne Mundspülungen. Für Bitch und Death. DJ Snake erlebt kein aufregendes Leben. Weil DJ Snake versucht erstmal alles richtig zu machen, bevor er sein erstes Album rauskriegt. Der muss erstmal das richtige Auto, die richtigen Brillis, die richtige Zahnzusatzversicherung. Dann ist er in der Rente und hat nie sein erstes Album rausgebracht. Das stimmt. Der arme DJ Snake. Ach ja, Leute. Es hat mir wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht heute Abend hier. Ey, wir mussten sagen, wir haben hier Bill Burr gesehen. Wir haben hier Bill Burr gesehen. Und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dass so, ich finde es irgendwie lustig, wenn wir an Orten spielen, wo man merkt, die Veranstalter, die haben schon mal was Besseres. Die denken vorher auch so, wer sind die Leute? Wir sind für viele von diesen Leuten der Beweis, dass die Kultur zugrunde geht. Die haben hier noch Opern gesehen und die Zauberflöte und jetzt kommen die Idioten, die irgendwie nebenbei Gags um eine Telegram-Gruppe machen und die Leute denken sich einfach, alles geht im Bach runter. Oder eine Milben essen will, der andere hat mir in der Show dreimal aufs Hände geguckt. Das ist halt so. Ey, Leute, unsere Prognosen, think about it, Sie werden alle eintreten. Think about it. Das war, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht, die letzte Folge in diesem Jahr. Oh, kann gut sein, zumindest die letzte vor Weihnachten. Lasst euch an, lasst euch an. Vielen Dank, Herr Antfeld, haut rein, ich habe auch sehr viel Spaß. Vielen Dank, Köln, vielen Dank, Bergisch Gladbach, vielen Dank, Düsseldorf, vielen Dank, Kron. Ihr wart grossartig, wir sehen uns gleich in unserem Werkstatt, wenn ihr wollt. Ansonsten macht's gut, ciao, wir heben ab!
Macht's gut, danke schön!